hey man get ready for film school
fridays where i'm just gonna talk about
filmmakers and the movies they make that
i love every week and uh with uh with
jake with luke
uh with vinnie with my friends i'm
saying them like they're rock stars they
will be by the time you listen to this
goddamn podcast but
uh
if you want to hear more of that kevin
smith and who the [ __ ] doesn't wanna uh
if you're like my mother and you're like
my god i can't get enough of this guy's
voice
come on join us over at that kevin smith
club man thatkevinsmithclub.com
i do a morning show five days a week
waking bake man where i just literally
wake up smoke weed and just talk at you
and [ __ ]
uh if if you're looking to throw a few
uh bucks my way for this free podcast
you're about to enjoy
jump on over to that kevin smith club uh
and join up right now man be a clerk i'm
all right a fun employee or a yoga hose
that's right i made the highest level
[ __ ] my least popular movie that's
how i roll
thatkevinsmithclub.com ladies and
gentlemen and now homeschool fridays
class is back in session welcome to film
school fridays i'm your host kevin smith
uh here we go
and episode two uh with me as uh as last
week
is jake wiseman jake s weissman yeah you
use the s i do use the s there's another
jake weissman out there leave off the s
for pretension what is that all about
what's with that there's a guy who has a
comedy central show and his name is jake
weissman so i was like just have it um
so the s is the adam f goldberg of it
all yeah it's the um david x cohen of it
all fair enough um but this week joining
us
uh luke uh works with us here at smodco
also working with the cirrus manko if
you've ever ordered a [ __ ] thing he
probably he's the he's the conduit man
if you were like oh my god that [ __ ]
sweet ass
watch was [ __ ] like bam he was your
guy if you're like oh my god the [ __ ]
movie pop the
j
a silent while reboot pops oh he was
your guy he was your conduit he was your
pusher man
uh give it up for luke taylor hey how's
it going luke uh is a filmmaker as well
yes
i have a name distinction too in my film
life i use my full name like when i do
it is that true look at you two [ __ ]
frogs we're late we're late in the game
it's not like a large von trier well
that's exactly what's going on well i
mean i think that's just his name right
no it's not the vaughn is not his name
his name is lars trier and he was such a
pretentious [ __ ] in film school that
they gave him the von and he took it
that's true that's the story that i know
it's never what i mean boy you came with
it with such authority i've read
certainty i'm like my god that must be
true
comes after me like i don't know like
isn't he like dutch or something like
that he's icelandic
and isn't vaughn a thing
means um
like royalty or something like that so
he's like a count so his name was lars
trier and they're like you're such a
you think so highly of yourself we'll
call you lars von trier and then he went
ahead una reversed it and said fine
that's fine by me is that where they're
teaching in film school these days i
mean not in mine i didn't know about
this like when they they they used their
own mind
a lot of other stuff i've been around
since the 90s i never heard this i
thought that was his [ __ ] name but
you know it could be in an era of uh the
information highway when
you know lars von trier is forever fixed
in in my perception but perhaps i'm not
you know a member of that lars von trier
club or something like that so i'm not
it's called dogma
they're true but i mean maybe i'm not as
as like i didn't keep my finger on the
pulse maybe that's something that broke
later but like you know what i have you
asked me for the apocryphal well kevin
you haven't you have a a producer on
clerks3 that's luke taylor so like on
your call sheet so like when i was like
starting my career not so long ago right
uh i had to like seek that out and be
like are there other luke taylor as well
confused more than one no there's no
lucas guy taylor that's just me so you
go by professionally lucas guy taylor
yeah it sounds douchey doesn't it yeah i
mean you know it's just like it's
it seems like the opposite it seems very
pronounced because you're like lucas guy
taylor it seems the opposite of pronoun
it seems like you're like making fun of
pronouns almost where you're like i'm
going to declare that i'm a man lucas
just so you know
very very i'm a little bit like behind
the curve luke has an adorable little
sidebar story luke got married how long
ago uh so august 2020
2020 oh my god in the midst of the
[ __ ] pandemic yeah um uh luke uh
last name as we know uh taylor whether
it's guy taylor or just taylor
taylor is always in play
um luke met a
a beautiful girl who
um
has a name
i'm trying to set it up properly but i'm
too stoned
luke met a girl named taylor correct
and go figure she fell for luke enough
to be like i will share my life with you
and change my name to yours although
professionally does she keep her old
name no she goes taylor taylor it was
like honestly i had a little bit of a
working of [ __ ] tails jordan monsanto
before we were married she's like she
has a changer name that kid is uh i mean
that's that's that what a [ __ ] taylor
square that's fantastic
yeah um there was ever a moment of
hesitation where she's like i'm not i
can't [ __ ] marry you because the last
name she didn't really uh no not on that
part but she didn't tell me she was
gonna officially change it or anything
like so for the longest time i assumed
she would just like keep it or some
people set a hyphen but now she went
ahead and did the whole the whole thing
taylor license says taylor taylor yeah
that's great yeah i mean and that's
amazing
with a dick so powerful
that he that he made a woman go like
yeah i will make a pun of my name yeah
from now until the [ __ ] grave i know
that's love dude my dick's got a good
personality
one of those things um the boys here
know each other uh as is often the case
everyone's like so you know in this
business it literally is
luke's been working with us for a while
and then we were like we need help and
so i assume you're the one that brought
in jake yeah from the from the clutches
of the midwest and you guys met each
other how when is this a film thing or
no not honestly not at all well two
filmmakers
from chicago yeah
who met out here no do you want to tell
it you want me to do it uh i mean i i'm
happy to i mean right now every [ __ ]
snyder verse fan is like [ __ ] move on
but
as we all know secret origins i have
more lars von trier anecdotes for all of
you
fans of snyder know that we did like
three different origin movies in this
four-hour movie so they can chill oh
they're very painful and let me tell you
if you're a snyder verse kid oh my god i
i suspect you're going to delight
uh from today's show this isn't like
sitting on fat man beyond where mark
tries to politically delicately
talk about his feelings for uh zack
snyder's justice league uh we'll be
doing a dive on uh zack snyder's justice
league tonight with somebody who has
wept through it i mean i mean i mean
i've cried through it i would say i mean
at the very least metaphorically right
like i mean i've literally cried when he
[ __ ] gets to the as much as i don't
want to when he gets to the dad oh part
which i want to make fun of it's like oh
that sounds like [ __ ] sofia coppola
as she's dying in godfather she's like
but like when he gets to the lot you
know once he starts telling the speech
that's pretty [ __ ] moving
um
they're you know what is it there's
something oh [ __ ]
is crazy
moving
when the little girl
with the perfectly [ __ ] shot eyes
like just the right [ __ ] light he's
gotten her eyes he's looking up at at
wonder woman like
can i be you some guy oh without it and
you're like oh my god that [ __ ] my my
wife is one of the coldest human beings
i've ever met
that makes her cry and she literally i i
just rewatched it today before we did
the show and she rolled by for the one
park she's like oh my god i [ __ ] love
this we're so much so that she's like we
love this right i'm like yes we do
um we love all of this you are very
selective your column mag column b
but when it gets to that part she like
clutch her [ __ ] chest and
her eyes were [ __ ] wet she was like
um and just that whole sequence that
[ __ ] wonder woman secret is one of
the greatest superhero sequences of all
time we're going to talk about
zack snyder's justice league uh
momentarily once we get past this origin
story
um
but uh first
back to you guys how is it that you know
each other so
we did meet in chicago i would i went to
chicago from like small town so i'm from
canton illinois
then bounced around to like macomb right
yeah i thought you were chicago well
once you're from chicago and you go to
la you just say chicago
you're
i'm from vermont but i spent half my
life in vermont half my life in chicago
you know what i mean so i went to uh
college at western then went to film
school for grad school or whatever uh
moved to chicago for that and then when
i was there i needed a job
uh lived in this neighborhood at the
very top of chicago there was a small
independently run movie theater called
the new 400.
jake's working there uh the
the gm at the time was from where i went
to college she helped get me the gig
uh and we just kind of became buzzed
from there we were a couple of clerks
honestly if you're going to turn to look
at them lovingly as you tell the story
you got to remember that you're getting
you know what's funny is like i've
listened to like so many pods of you and
i even at home i was like make sure you
talk in the mic my suggestion my
suggestion will be this turn yeah i mean
yeah just turn it that way because
you're it seems like you want to get a
dynamic it's hard to look at yourself
i know i just little screech as soon as
i do it oh my god [ __ ] the dog was
just [ __ ] barking feel free to move
the chair i know
um but yeah so happenstance
that's the connection that's yeah the
movie theater to take it even further
back like for people who are like how do
you get a job in that organization once
again it really helps
it's who you know
you came to us luke by way by
weird way yeah of smash of ashley who
used to be my assistant like who [ __ ]
drove me around and stuff like that you
know uh
everyone knows [ __ ] specially from
the podcast and stuff well maybe not
from this podcast ashley green
not to be confused with the ashley green
from [ __ ] 20. not that one
uh ashley used to be my assistant drove
me around forever and ever and stuff
um
she
told jordan oh there's a guy who's in
town
who she didn't necessarily know you no
but her friend marissa
was the connection yeah i'm like third
hand from ashley in a weird way it all
traces back to her her and marissa knew
each other from vegas right uh i met
marissa when i moved to chicago in film
school and she was like oh my god my
friend ashley is kevin smith's assistant
you're a kevin smith fan i was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's really sweet so yeah
many rules of joints i'm like very cool
uh and that's why it's kind of bizarre
it's a good job it's like here we are so
uh that was really strange and when she
she went she came out here a little bit
before me i left chicago a little bit
after
uh and i just you know i didn't have a
gig out out here or anything me and
taylor had just gotten engaged and we
were like you know taylor's an actor i'd
gotten my masters at depaul on
screenwriting i'd i'd already made a
feature at that point so i was ready to
come out here and try it out and um
marissa happened to like
have an interview with jordan um
like a week after i got here uh and then
it ended up being like here's the gig
marissa ended up being busy with some
other stuff and like i got a text from
jordan like that day so i've been in la
for like 11 days
uh i mean with no money and like we had
an apartment and taylor was like
teaching kids like in china at night
like on skype at like 3 a.m and that was
her only source of income and it was a
total luck like i mean total stroke of
luck and happenstance and also sure like
who you know um that i got passed along
i interviewed with rebecca like that day
um and he's been with us ever since uh
luke as previously mentioned
professionally goes by lucas guy taylor
yeah um has directed and recently
directed a short film with taylor taylor
in it acting and then and um you got a
geriatric uh [ __ ]
one of those old-timer [ __ ] actors
that like oh where's that [ __ ]
ben pull him out of mothballs to give a
performance for you yeah i mean he he's
old man i couldn't believe it you look
great short film is called the bleed
purple and you've just been started like
it's been playing festivals yeah we're
starting to get in we uh they love kevin
japan like we played in japan last
weekend and you won best actor
at the top indie film awards
i'm [ __ ] packing it up in here i'm
moving to japan becoming like a local
actor there oh man get real we got to
get that plaqued up in here do they have
ganja in japan i mean no i think it's
very illegal i think it's very illegal
among others you know what kids i'm back
[Laughter]
um but yeah and so we're getting into
some things we got into like the oregon
short festival and we're playing at love
your shorts in florida and we've applied
to so many others so it's it's been a
ball but um
i mean it couldn't happen without you
man without i mean just on on one end
just to like you know it literally could
not literally i was a guy who was just
like oh i'll be in it yeah i mean you
literally like it doesn't work without
you and and not only that but like
it literally doesn't work without you
you could have filled my role any number
of ways
well i'm just saying like when you like
you could show up and just be there but
you knocked it out of the [ __ ] park
man like you've like truly anybody
that's seen it is like holy [ __ ]
silent he is not silent bob he isn't
like i gave you a million words to say
and you absolutely like elevated it i
always love that because it's it's a
nice like um
oh this is what like it could have been
like if i just did that
like if i just said words yeah as
opposed to like wrote words or [ __ ]
didn't say words because like i'm you
know i was like well i'll be silent
but it was fun it was absolutely fun to
do now
uh
and that's to set the stage to tell you
that uh we got some sin east not just
some armchairs and east film twitter you
know some
two cats who are like i like movies as
much as the next guy this is my
letterbox to count i'm talking about
they actually
have made you've made a film i've got a
feature what's it called my feature is
called break you can watch it on amazon
prime jesus starring uh taylor shepherd
at the time taylor taylor now and then
my buddy arie fiampolsky uh kelsey
bunner who i also helped kind of she
worked for us this summer yeah uh she
produced bleed purple as well that's a
canton kid for where i'm from i keep
just bringing everybody i've ever met
and you would be local
and whatnot so that's there and then we
made a i shot a short right in rogers
park called winnie and charlotte's last
night at the oasis it's also on amazon
prime um and you've shot features well
we talked about last i shot two features
two features where can they see them or
then or is there no amazon prime no you
can watch my first one scrapers on
amazon
uh is that a thing with the kids now you
just put it up listen it's going away
now we hit that we were right at the the
spike and i stole it from him it's a
storied kind of a thing where we were
like luke said we were there at the
exact perfect moment where they were
trying to get
people on to amazon and this is really
an episode in and of itself so i'll keep
it really quick
but it was like after one festival they
were like you know what everyone who
uh didn't get into the festival
will give you ten thousand dollars you
can have uh you can upload onto amazon
are you [ __ ] and they were like no
because i spent five million dollars on
my movie ten thousand dollars is nothing
well me i'm like [ __ ] like
let's make a movie for ten thousand
dollars and see what we can do
now the
that uh award wasn't there because
that's part of the festival thing that
being said they were letting people just
upload their [ __ ] and make money like it
was spotify that being said once they
bought bond and kind of are like they're
like you know what
unless you're making us money you can't
keep your [ __ ] on here is that right yes
sir so remember the early days of prime
where it was like
like i remember for some reason we
talked about putting
hollywood babylon upon
fair prime or something like that but um
wow that is familiar so
it can't be done anymore i don't know if
you can upload it's just it what what it
is is that my movie's on there you have
to rent it for 3.99 or no you rent it
for 2.99 or buy it for 3.99 we get to
set the price
um
that's something i stole from tusk
actually because that was the the one
dollar price difference got me to buy
tusk as opposed to rent tusk and i was
like i'm gonna steal that
um
but uh
you can't be streaming free on prime so
people were watching my [ __ ] because
they were like they're scrolling around
they find break they're scrolling around
they find winnie and charlotte and it's
a cool piece of art and you click on it
and wow you get some minutes once you
actually have to start paying for
something that you've never heard of
before that's when things start getting
kind of dead so i don't i haven't been
paying attention they like pulled us
down like you know you we had the blue
check mark like when we right when we
uploaded like his feature first and i
stole it from him and did it with my
feature all you have to do is
pay the money to some service for them
to do your closed captioning so as long
as you have the closed captioning file
and submit the proper like files of art
and your flick you're good to go but
they pulled a lot of that stuff away
from like now it's a paywall and then
like i swear to god it was like two
weeks after i posted my short like it
wasn't too long after i started for
smodco they were like no more shorts
yeah and also no documentaries like
nobody and uh so like my short lived on
prime for like a week and now it's like
my four minute shorts buying like a 99
cent paywall it's like never going to
happen but it feels legitimate if you
say amazon prime doesn't matter
i'm impressed in this business nearly 30
years i'm like you're on prime what are
you doing working for me doesn't it
sound cool doesn't it sound cool
imagine how it was four years ago when
we were telling everyone you can see you
know the trailers and our names and
everything like that all you need to do
is tell people you're on amazon prime so
that's pretty cool my other feature is
on it's serialized on youtube
um and it's called clean sheet you
snyder cutted it you put it in the
chapters after the fact
i i have a feature version of it if you
go to jelly roll
jellyrollchicago.com and go to my vimeo
you can watch everything for free um and
that's i have the feature and it's i
didn't get a chance to finish shooting
it so it's only 65 minutes long but it
is a feature oh you just totally
disclaimered it don't disclaim it
it's a great film it is so adorable
listening to the next generation of
filmmakers
okay so that's just a long way of saying
uh the kids have credentials a lot of
people talk about film
when they have an opinion that differs
from somebody else one of the first
go-to defenses criticisms put-downs is
like where's your [ __ ] movie well
when you disagree with whatever the boys
say on the episode
hold your where's your [ __ ] movie you
now know where their movies are go give
us that one star review on amazon
let's get to it because they're a bunch
of hungry snyder verse fans who are like
are you kidding me insatiable stop
[ __ ] talking about each other and
talk about zach it's very easy to talk
about zach zach is one of the most
lovable filmmakers i've ever met in my
life and bar none
one of the 10 most talented
um when i watch zack snyder film
it is uh
it it leaves me with the distinct
impression like oh
i'm a tourist and have been for many
years i make movies
he makes movies you know what i'm saying
so he's one of those filmmakers he's
like a
a spielberg a nolan
a rodriguez uh tarantino where you're
like were these [ __ ] born with a
camera in their hands when they come out
the womb were they born wearing choppers
and a [ __ ] tilted beret
i'm [ __ ] with a megaphone in hand
so
um
that just goes without saying and
you know i think he's like for most
people for me i know he did a bunch of
commercial work but he popped up on my
radar with dawn of the dead
which
is a
ballsy
entree
you know i mean i'm sure he's not like
that's the one i'm picking that's
fortune came his way and they were like
hey do you want to take a stab at this
and he had an original take on it you
know uh along with the screamer i'm sure
there somebody else wrote the script oh
wasn't it
james gone screenplay that's right oh my
god so you're already loaded for bear
with [ __ ] james gunn screenplay same
weekend as scooby-doo that he wrote the
[ __ ] they both came out like around the
same time whatever happened to james
gunn he was he was living so much from a
guy
and now he's just a drama guy forever a
german guy poor guy so um
dawn of the dead is incredibly ballsy
because uh you're talking to a 70s kid
who literally watched dawn of the dead
happen
unlike y'all when you were still just
[ __ ] [ __ ] balls and eggs and
whatnot
i was literally re-watching [ __ ]
george romero
to make this brilliant movie
about not just a horror movie but oh my
god [ __ ] zombies in bed and this time
it's an enclosed structure and it ain't
black and white [ __ ] a like these
zombies are in color and it's also kind
of funny there's some funny [ __ ] going
on i'm young and i could still
understand social commentary of like
this taking place in a [ __ ] shutdown
mall and don't think it wasn't
influential
i did wind up shooting eventually you
know at the monroeville mall that's
right so
as a long way of saying there's a high
bar if you're going to make a picture
like dawn of the dead
um and win me over you know what i'm
saying he did it's a wonderful movie
like it does does nothing to discredit
george romero's classic and becomes an
instant classic in and of itself and
right then and there i'm like my god
what a filmmaker to pay attention to
next up was 300 yeah that's that's the
one i mean like that's the one that that
is as bad as i felt watching dawn of the
dead going like yeah i know filmmaker
when i saw 300 i was like good christ
good christ am i even the same breathing
living animal the same species as this
man
he was able to take a
frank miller comic bro a frank miller
book not just a comic book but a frank
miller comic book and not just like hey
sin city but [ __ ] 300 which you know
simple straightforward story that's been
told before but frank's telling of it
it you know it's beautiful but at the
same time it's not like oh this is going
to be accessible to everybody you know
[ __ ] felt like breathing rarefied air
and zach comes along and makes this
sumptuous gorgeous living comic book
version of the movie true
graphic novel come to life and
establishes the style that he'll work in
for the rest of his career especially
when it comes at least to the these
comic book flicks he he's a splash pager
when you're reading a comic book and you
get to a single page where there's just
a stunning image not a series of panels
as a splash page when you get to
two of them side by side double splash
page man usually reserved for incredible
group shots credit pages something
stunning stunning
visuals can impact and just sear itself
uh in the mind of the viewer the reader
that's how zach works every [ __ ]
frame
is a [ __ ] splash page like no panels
in a zack snyder
comic book movie and that was
established as early on as [ __ ] 300
uh which was a huge [ __ ] hit dawg
that was a big hit too but like 300 was
like what
so after 300 what happens what does he
do
uh does it what is it
which
sucker punch is a hard watch right in
there stunning though like i remember
seeing the trailer and being like this
guy cracked the code like holy [ __ ] he
just reinvented cinema and then when you
see the movie
i mean there's a lot of interesting
ideas and but still visually stunning
well i feel like the crux of this
episode and the crux of all this is that
when i watched a lot of these movies i
didn't know that there were these other
cuts
so
the four-hour watchmen watchman
we're sitting here being like what was
that the four-hour watchmen were there
it's like watchmen you [ __ ] right now
they've disavowed us this conversation
we're working on it we're getting there
yeah um i finally got to watch the
version with like the animated gerard
butler uh comic thing and it's a
beautiful i love the four hour version
and uh i wasn't crazy about bvs we'll
get to that then luke turn me on to it
turn me on to the extended cut of it and
boy do i enjoy that so it all leads to
the snyder cut i feel and
you know 300 is absolutely seminal
and um
uh take you back to the watchman because
washington is where i crossed paths with
zach for the first time i was on a panel
in the year that it was uh going to be
coming out and so it was uh mark
bernardin fat man beyond oh yeah
was bargain entertainment weekly and
programmed this panel uh [ __ ] i forget
what it was
i want to say icons but i don't know if
that's it might be a little too
self-important but it was like the ideas
you're some [ __ ] heavy hitters in the
in the genre
and it was uh for me a fortuitous c to
because put me up there with like apatow
who was like [ __ ] just broke huge as
apatow at that moment
zack snyder who's just dropping the
trailer for watchmen at that [ __ ] san
diego comic con
frank miller oh my god um and me
i can't remember if there was somebody
else but if i forgot somebody
apologies it's a good group it's a
pretty [ __ ] stellar group and uh
and so um i got to blow up zach there
backstage about like that trailer
because they dropped the trailer with
the uh
the
uh was not
a
smashing pumpkin song okay that was like
the first trailer that they dropped and
you know it for as somebody who's a long
time watchman reader and lover
stunning because you were like jesus he
did it like
same way he did 300 he's like literally
doing
[ __ ] like
gibbons and more or gibbons because
moore doesn't like to be associated with
it outside of
the original medium so
you know i i told him backstage i was
like i gave him a big hug i think i
talked to him i said it on the panel
but i was like you were doing the lord's
work man that [ __ ] looks
astounding and it delivered i loved the
watch movie some people had an issue
with the ending because it didn't have
the giant squid
i thought
their fix was totally [ __ ] good like
i didn't bump into it
as much as some people did i love don't
get me wrong i love the hbo watchman
series
it was absolutely [ __ ] brilliant but
there you go you like with any comic
book adaptation and i think that's going
to be at the root of our discussion
today
you have source material
being filtered through the prism of so
many different artists and
in this tribal society we have pop
culture society
um where people are like this is mine
this is what i identify with and that
means that any other iteration of this
[ __ ] blows and is against what i
stand for
it's tough for people to kind of
maybe take the perspective that i've had
as a long time comic book fan and and
that's usually the prism through which i
view zach's
dc movies
there are
so many iterations of these characters
that can be done
so many different
permutations
i'm used to that from the world of
comics because in detective batman was
handled one way
in batman comics he was handled another
way in [ __ ] keith giffen's justice
league there were jokes like you know no
matter which filter it's going through
there's a different iteration of the
character but i was never like well [ __ ]
this i mean look i'll be honest i was a
bit judgy
about some art man i don't know why but
i would give jim apparel a real hard
time he's a classic batman artist
um but like you know i was always like
this looks like coloring book batman
because i was looking for like you know
i schooled on frank miller dark knight
so i'm like give me something dramatic
mike mignola [ __ ] batman covers from
you know death in the family but i
definitely grew to love jim apparel
stuff um however you know we all have
tastes we all have preference and
whatnot but i learned how to appreciate
everyone's different takes on a
character
and not be like you know just be like
this is the one i prefer
but they're all there's room for
everything and i appreciate a bunch of
different takes so
i grew up watching the superman you know
i grew up watching the black and white
one on tv and reruns as a child and then
super friends and then of course the
dick donner movies and forward
um
you know so i i there's a
famously i worked on a version of
superman that never happened um
something about that or infamously i
should say
so you know there's a oh i know what a
superman movie is and then zach
makes man of steel
and it's like this is also a superman
movie
and for some people it's a generational
divide where they're like well [ __ ]
that ain't my superman and it's like
well
i mean look that ain't the superman i
grew up with but [ __ ] any superman
better than no superman and i'm
interested
in alternative take zach's take was
always meant to be
what if this [ __ ]
was real
and that's the prism he puts everything
through
and appreciated that way
you know it
it's not very controversial
but because we live in such a
very pop culturally tribal culture
um
it's
it's
divisive you can't just like a [ __ ]
thing right without hating a thing at
the same time i come from a different
place
where look i'll take a different [ __ ]
take on batman every day
from a different artist you know across
the boards that
they're these characters be them dc
marvel and let's just keep it there
um
because the star wars line is a very
specific story being told
but the dc characters and marvel
characters quite like your biblical
characters or your greek mythological
characters
you know can be used to interpret
different moral stories uh you know
different can be interpreted differently
through
every teller nobody does it the same
[ __ ] way you know
i remember when they were teaching us
the greek myths they left out a lot of
the [ __ ] you know and then zeus
turned into a [ __ ] rainstorm and
[ __ ] a goat in front of a woman
because that's the way he rolled you
know that's a true story
that's true
[Laughter]
so at the end of the day it's like
sometimes you leave this off you leave
this off or whatever but like
you know these characters are so big
that they can be
handled by multiple storytellers
and told in many different ways and
i still appreciate them all
like you know i mean
zack's take on the dc universe
is is very auteur driven
whereas let's say the
you know the justice league that most
folks are used to is the dc animated
series or and or the super friends if
you count that from back in the day
um you know you get a little bit on the
smallvilles of this world and the arrow
versus they bring people together but
generally speaking let's
leave it to the cartoon
cartoon is fantastic
um and you know it is built by auteurs
so to speak same team a lot of the same
team that brought together batman the
animated series but then in order for a
thing like that to work
it has to be generic enough that anybody
can jump into the lead roles and the
show can go on
so
we're used to a more and i this is not
meant to be dismissive because i worship
at the [ __ ] altar of the justice
league cartoon
but that's
a a
a mainstream and or and i don't mean
this in a negative way generic take on
the material generic meaning
i could hire luke to write an episode i
can hire luke to write an episode i
pointed at jake jake to write an episode
i don't know and then i can hire other
people to write an episode and they'll
all feel the same because
let's say jake's like well i brought in
some of my father issues it's like not
not in this [ __ ] show
and that individuality gets hammered out
and stuff
you know in the case of zack's movies
you're talking about as well they're as
auteur driven as it gets as most people
have thrown me into the auteur category
my whole life because like oh he's
[ __ ] you could tell a [ __ ] kevin
smith movie you know they're all bad but
he's the same thing he's like you could
tell [ __ ] take his name off the
credit tell zack snyder movie very
auteur driven has been since he
jumped in the driver's seat of even
something like donald daddy put a
signature style on it and built upon
that signature style to get to the point
where they were like here to big toys
and then use that signature style on the
big toys and it was met
with
mixed results like right down the middle
it seemed like yeah and it was not as
embraced he didn't have as easy a time
of it as most of the marvel flicks had
um you know the man steal the take on
man of steel
was oh well this is serious and mo and a
lot of people got caught up on oh he
broke his [ __ ] neck right he killed
zod you know but it's like he killed zod
and superman too as well yeah but he
just you know didn't [ __ ] snap his
neck in front of the family i guess
maybe that grossed people out
and the utter destruction of metropolis
the destruction porn really seemed to
rub people the wrong way as him and zod
you know it felt like oh the movie's
over and then there was another 20
minutes of like we're going to be the
[ __ ] out of each other until the city's
destroyed however gave birth to i mean
look i love that movie but it also gave
birth to one of my favorite sequences of
film of all time and one i watch over
and over again the opening of batman vs
superman dawn of justice where you see
the entire [ __ ] sequence of man of
steel from the ground from bruce wayne's
point of view and as a real nerdy [ __ ]
i'm like
i i had no idea when we were watching
man of steel that he was too
and he was like in the same position as
us i mean granted he had a cooler car
and he ran faster and he was at the
center of danger but he too was a
witness to all of this it's nuts
um
so he's got a friend named jack
but that means a lot to him kevin that
that's true he's very passionate about
jack in the opening as a big dc fan i'm
like i could have been somebody else why
couldn't that have been lucious he's
like okay well but then but then zach's
like all right fine i'll use a dc
character and then then jimmy olsen gets
plugged like
don't you think don't my take on jimmy
olsen
was
he's a ci agent absolutely so his the
code name is jimmy olsen oh they had a
jenny olson
in superman and bvs so they already have
their
olson character copy so to me i didn't
say like oh that was jimmy olsen he
[ __ ] killed jimmy olsen i didn't care
i as a jimmy olsen fan i did
i worked it out in my own head where i'm
like that's the guy is admitted cia
operative he's not a [ __ ] real
photographer so that can't be jimmy
olsen yeah that's his name he picked a
standard [ __ ] name to be like i'm
jimmy olsen blowing my mind right now is
where does zack hang out was this thing
vevo or whatever
oh what is it it's like that it's a
social media i don't even know what it
is it looks like xango wherever he hangs
out maybe see i'll help he'll confirm or
deny
whether that theory works he might just
be like no that is jimmy olsen i i'm
sure somewhere i just wanted to kill
jimmy
look which if he did that's like yeah
it's your prerogative like you know
that's that's part of
part of the uv i mean his idea
going in and i've read it many times was
he was just like look
like this is what would happen
like this you know if two gods fight
[ __ ] the city gets destroyed and
that's what i like to play with and you
know these characters are huge metaphors
and and you know yeah there's collateral
damage otherwise
why the [ __ ] do we need him like he
warrants the use of a superhero by
destroying a city uh by saying like look
without what would it be like without
these [ __ ] you know what i'm saying so
it
you know it's extreme for some folks
but again i
i just dial it back to
all right so if i were to put this
through the
prism of my years of reading dc comics
this is an extraordinary elseworlds tale
yeah to me
now
to some folks they're like that's the
[ __ ] canon that's the [ __ ]
universe don't even talk like it's else
worlds and [ __ ] like that i ain't
labeling it as such i'm just saying
that's what a long time reader
that's how i [ __ ] came to peace with
it where i was like yeah man this is
this is what you would do if you were
like give somebody the timeline and let
them do whatever they want and they keep
close to the story but
their flourishes perhaps are a bit more
dramatic a bit more arch or a bit more
you know extreme than than the
flourishes of of others who've handled
the material and stuff you know i you
know i as a guy who was a big fan of
of course like adam west's batman was
the one i watched on tv growing up but
like when tim burton handled it in 1989
you know could you imagine
in if you left the theater in 1980 and
june 23rd 1989 you just watched [ __ ]
batman and somebody was like come next
door i'm going to show you the future
and then they showed you this batman oh
my god like
it would [ __ ] melt your mind that
would be it would be too much we're like
this is where we go holy [ __ ] how long
to get there and you're like a long time
[ __ ] michael j fox playing johnny be
good and [ __ ]
he was like
i guess you weren't ready for that yeah
your kids will love it
that's snyder's whole career
he sets the stage with the man of steel
and bvs continues and then also
is controversial because he uh
you know people like what
uh
and like critically boy oh boy the score
on that is like it's like one of the
latter kevin smith movies yeah it's like
yoga hoser's country when you look at
that score but you know what does that
mean some people are like well credit
scores mean and i'm like you're saying
that to me
so um at the end of the day
the uh
whether or not you know uh people
embrace the movie or not
bvs is a stunning achievement um i
remember seeing the trailer for that at
[ __ ] comic-con and being like oh my
god he's literally almost making [ __ ]
the dark knight returns and i hope the
tail end of all this one day
you know it's like
in reboot culture you know whether it
takes five ten years from now
when zach comes back
to warner brothers fingers crossed to
play with those characters again
i i think you should just flat out do
dark knight returns at this point i mean
it's damn clear he wants to like i mean
obvi like you know he loves frank miller
from as far back as 300 and before
that's how you that's that's the way to
return i mean to be like you know what
here zack snyder's return presents
would you feel it redundant because he
used so many pieces in bvs i wouldn't
not personally no and you're like are
you [ __ ] nuts like i watched a movie
where at the end
batman and the joker teamed up to stop
the end of the world like that that's
the deal yeah i'm ready to go it's like
in a world where he seems very
comfortable on streaming now like uh
like netflix has embraced him uh his his
latest zombies like is so dope like and
and he
made two at a time like somehow like
because they already have the seat like
in jersey too he went to atlantic city
i didn't realize all the stuff in the
casino was a
casino in atlantic city they were just
about to blow up that movie comes out at
the same time the justice league is a
streaming exclusive you know what i mean
he seems very cool in there and like and
he's in a spot where it doesn't have to
be an ultimate edition if you give me
six episodes i'll finally get to tell a
story i want dark knight returns is a
perfect spot to do that he could go
issue by issue panel by panel who cares
if we've seen batman in front of the
lightning strike in bvs i'll i'll watch
it again let's see it again yeah you
know what i mean like let's let's make
ben even bigger how much bigger can we
make ben like can we shoot him at like
seven five and this you know what i mean
like you know what's crazy though is the
as as justice league closes
it has been at his not biggest
in terms of like the the [ __ ]
sheer muscle tonnage he put on for bbs
yeah but it has been looking his
absolute [ __ ] best oh like the marsh
like when he when he gets out of [ __ ]
bed and talks to the martian manhunter
he looks [ __ ] stunning
stunning nobody's looking at the alien
like i should have been excited that the
martian man owner made his dc movie
debut but i was like
look at how good bruce wayne looks in
pajama pants yeah oh my god i was ready
to follow that movie like once marsha
manhart took off it's like make
breakfast oh
what do you do well i'd watch the snyder
cut of the workout sequence when he's
training and to put on the the metal
suit or whatever and he remembers and
he's like flipping tires and smacking
stuff with like and just screaming and
we you know showering and [ __ ] no
for those oh i'm sure it exists
somewhere it sounds like it exists in
your heart i mean well at taylor's like
again with ben shower
like it's what makes a marriage work
so uh when uh
you know uh justice we all know the back
story but
briefly uh they go make justice league
and in the midst of it a lot of things
go wrong including personal tragedy and
zack's life and he steps away from the
movie uh and or the movies flat out
taken away from him uh he wants to put
it to the side naturally to deal with
family stuff
studio wanted to make money
finish it put it out so
they brought in uh joss whedon which i
remember at one point was the thing that
people like all right yeah like the guy
that made avengers
like you know
[ __ ] sure he'll help
um
and as we all saw that really wasn't the
case
um so
then uh
something historical happened
um
uh you know
there have been directors who have uh
put out their
director's cuts and extended cuts of
films in the past and there's always
been the director's prerogative um the
studio's prerogative
i can't think of a time where the
audience
made something happen
and the audience literally made it
happen hashtag released the snyder cut
was a movement that uh was so big it
went beyond social media and people
talked about it and [ __ ] the real
news and whatnot
and affected change there was this uh
campaign to see
the real movie um we talked about it way
early on before i think it was before
and i ain't taking credit at all
uh so please don't [ __ ] put it
through that filter but like before that
was organized i think we were talking
about it on fat man beyond because jamie
in the audience cat ears had been in a
test screening
and so i had talked about being on the
set
of the star wars movie in england where
they had shot both justice leagues
and so there were dudes who worked on
the crew who were like giving me the
inside dope and they were like oh my god
zax was
incredible
so much better and they were telling me
like what was playing they had these
long boards drawn out by jim lee of what
was going to be happening and [ __ ] which
included dark side and i was like what
are you talking about no way
then during an episode of fat men beyond
at the cantina
uh jamie caddy or sits like right up
front she was off to the side that night
i remember
she had seen an early test screening of
justice league pre joss whedon wow
which included
like it wasn't she said it wasn't
finished and there was a lot of like you
know storyboards and previz art and
stuff but it included [ __ ] that fucker's
head getting cut off and going through
the hole and dark side standing there
yeah and i was like what the [ __ ] and so
we talked about and then
again i ain't taking credit for it by
any stretch of meditation i'm just
saying we talked about it and then this
happened but it it felt like later on
like other people were
hey man yeah i want to see this [ __ ]
thing too and for all i know they were
talking about before even we talked
about on the episode of fat man beyond
regardless
um
that released the snyder cut movement
got [ __ ] huge and to the point that
warner brothers literally
listened and fortuitously warner
brothers was starting their own
streaming channel
uh they wanted to go big
and you know they were like [ __ ]
give the people what they want like the
whole the whole of the internet is
saying they want to see this
long-ass cut zack snyder's cut of the
justice league
let's do it and so they announced that
they were going to do zack snyder's
justice league version of justice league
called zack snyder's justice league
which was the his vision from start to
finish
uncut they didn't know if they were
releasing it
separately or is one big unit but
but we all at that point knew he had the
bunch money 50 to 70 million to finish
it
and make it
a movie um because there was a lot of
there there was always like controversy
does it exist this does the snugger cut
even exist
and the
answer was yes and no a version of it
existed but like
was it one you could put in theaters no
it clearly needed to be finished and
effects needed to be done and scenes
needed to be enhanced with the visual
effects mama
so that money they got
to do that on hbo max
got them a completed movie got them back
to exactly what he would have done and
even better
than what he would have done back when
you know he was directing the movie and
before he was replaced
um he got to tell the exact
story he wanted to tell because he they
would not let him do a [ __ ] four-hour
movie back then
uh coming off bvs not by any stretch of
the imagination so it wound up like with
the snyder caught on hbo max they were
like all right [ __ ] go for it put
everything in
every piece counts go for it well i just
mean that he like there there's a lot of
things that like he wasn't getting
official permission to do so like
they're like no black suit superman and
so like he i remember he said something
like he shot it or colored it a certain
way to when if you were to be able to
get to go back through it all they had
to do was do one thing to make his suit
look black and silver it's not like he
was wearing a different one you know uh
like just like little like it almost
feels like safety nets he like left in
place in case something were to happen
smart uh i what happened first does the
son does the sonic the hedgehog movie
get bullied by the internet first and
then snyder cut is that way after i in
my mind snyder cut happens first and uh
sonic happened after because sonic
happened like a minute ago copy i just
didn't know if one influenced the other
and got it going because for a while it
felt like maybe i'm wrong though but i
this this
well this is there's influence in terms
of like the you know look one could go
as far back as snakes on a plane to say
the internet influence
sure this is more about
the internet
like gets a film
released
a director's cut an uncut version of the
movie release that's never happened
before they've released uncut versions
of the movie but i don't think an
audience
demand has ever
done this before peter jackson if you
ever want um does he ever done long
versions of the rings picture he has but
that's because he likes to do that they
swear by him like the people that are
hardcore rings i got a lot of my friends
i i have nothing but respect for them i
don't super
uh but i like
they swear by the extent those extended
versions are incredible
they really are and especially now in a
time where we're used to watching a
12-hour movie right um and that's really
the difference by way of our streaming
by the way by way of our streaming shows
you know when we worked at a movie
theater a four-hour movie is not
logistically possible explain okay
there's only so many seats that i have
there's only so many shows i can show in
a day
if i have a four hour movie we talked
about showing the irishman and we
couldn't get the turn around we can't
make any money off of that unless you
sell
you do it and it's in maybe justice
league we would have been able to do it
but i don't think we would have been
able to
um offer that kind of real estate the
same way we had three theaters playing
black panther when black panther was out
because it was a four house independent
um very small theater it's like look
when we got blade runner 2049 it's like
the employee you can only show it three
times as opposed to four times the
employees have to stay until 2 a.m
waiting for it and so you better hope
you sell out a lot of popcorn on blade
runner 2049 otherwise we paid a lot for
it this is what you're hearing right now
ladies and gentlemen is the movie the
real
business talk of the real movie business
we're on the floor in the trenches you
really are you guys are [ __ ] the
first line of offense like this is where
it all [ __ ] goes it's nice to hear
you say that yes
we're all in the movie business together
like two years ago we're sweeping up
popcorn and listening to this podcast
it's like in a messed up theater like
100 so like this is this is a delight to
hear you say that it's very this is as
vindicating as the snyder it's true
exhibition i remember i'll never forget
we were on a panel in uh south by
southwest 1997. and it's a panel of very
cool filmmakers that i probably the only
reason i was on it was because that
chasing amy happened that year so you're
a very cool fellow thank you kevin
you're very sweet you guys are scared
you can see why they got him so cool so
cool um so who's on the panel
robert rodriguez is on the panel quentin
tarantino's on the panel mike judge is
on the panel
uh i'm on the [ __ ] panel
uh george wang's on the panel
uh that's a big [ __ ] panel am i
listening
was coppola on that panel who's sophia
sofia no i think she was in terms of
that movie i think that's after us after
97 like a couple of years after nice i
think she's in the auts right well
that's lost in translation i don't know
when virgin suicides came out oh no that
was like uh let me say
that was like dogma year 99 or something
like that um so in any event we're on
this panel 97
and somebody asks like some question
about how do i get to be you like
[ __ ] and would be filmmaker
and quentin gave the response of like
don't
don't be us don't be a filmmaker there's
too many filmmakers you know what you
want to be a film distributor a film
exhibitor it's like that's what there's
not enough of and that they're getting
fewer and farther between my god was he
prophetic you know how many [ __ ]
distributors exist now
like we live in a world where disney now
owns fox so
the pool's getting smaller
to be fair yes
to be fair the pool's also getting
bigger and as much as they're making
more content than ever right uh but it's
fewer people making more content
so uh
the the these cats
know a thing or two about the movie
business man they know something about
having to put asses in [ __ ] seats
uh they and and as two
avowed
justice league fans you turned luke
turned jake into a justice league thing
correct uh it's a big i had to like more
so than that i sort of like it was like
a friendship test where i'm like we're
not real friends until i make you watch
batman v superman extended cut like six
times until you get it i'll say you
understand i i wouldn't have any of it i
saw the original cuts and then luke
started working at the theater and at
the theater you work eight hour shifts
and you have to kind of like the person
you're working with right because
there's a lot of down time and then said
down time he he turned me on
zack snyder almost 100 and got me to
watch all these movies he got me to
watch the andrew garfield spider-man
movies this year for the first time like
he gets me to watch all of this stuff
and thank goodness he did
so uh because
well that's a different episode
but vindication for fans of comic book
movies that were maybe divisive that's
kind of the move lately also i worked i
may have said this in a previous episode
but i worked every marvel movie from
winter soldier to endgame i worked every
star wars movie that was all of them you
know so i
people would always ask like oh you must
watch all these movies and i'm like do
you come into your job on your day off
because i'm too busy working i still
haven't seen black panther because i
work that too hard get out of here yeah
i mean it's a weird no you do you get
sore with it or like you get like you'll
get triggered if you hear a song that
was like the credit song of a movie you
swept up to it's four times a day for
three weeks how did i accidentally know
this song
see you post credits we could probably
recite them and order like like a
[ __ ] like book of poetry
don't get
of a marvel movie when you're working at
a movie theater you know why why because
everyone sits in their seats and you
can't clean the damn theater while
people are waiting in line in the lobby
so one of our favorite parts as an
audience of a marvel movie is the least
favorite part of an usher it's difficult
it is it's challenging i don't care
because i'm so die hard marvel i'm like
watching it with them like yes like are
you allowed to clean up while the
credits are on you have to do what you
can and work around people but also not
kick people out it did get to a point
where if we knew that there was only
like amid credits and not an end credits
we'd be like there's nothing left just
so you know you don't have to listen to
us but just so you know there's nothing
left and that would get most everybody
out
clean that's that's the movement i don't
know if i'd believe you i'd be my i'd be
like that might be a dirty day you are
what i'm not that unique in that one i
think so there were people like oh wait
always always
saying to you visually
[ __ ] you i think you're lying yes
it doesn't it doesn't start there but
also like not either we know we're right
right so more power to you it's your you
paid for the ticket it's your right to
sit through all of the end credits right
and i will and i never like turning
lights on like
you know the the house lights on before
the movie or the credits are done kind
of a thing if people are still sitting
there because that's rude um different
if you have 20 theaters too we worked in
a four theater like like
cheapest theater in chicago like
everybody was like you know i mean like
we had like in a very small lobby so it
[ __ ] us over because we had to move
people in and out in a very short period
of time if you have 20 theaters i mean
like at the big theaters they can they
can wait until the movies completely
done then roll their wagon in but it
just didn't work that way luke's
absolutely right we had um it's a narrow
pathway it's four theaters that held
about 400 people in the lobby held about
50.
and so we we would have said four
theaters 400 100 apiece about gotcha
there there was two theaters that had
about a hundred one of them that had
like 30 and one of them that had like a
little bit back in the olden days like
one theater and then yeah split it up or
whatever so like to take it back to
justice league yes if you did
a
four-hour screening of that movie how
long do you have to leave between the
next show oh no so like on a week night
we could only show so on a week night
during school if we opened up like four
we could only show that seven o'clock
right we could only show it once maybe
twice and if we showed it twice you'd
have to keep your like three college age
employees there until like two in the
morning to walk very well we did some
transformers movies that wouldn't end
until like one in the morning and i was
like cool transformers eight like thank
you it was like the wahlberg one at that
point i was like oh my gosh we found a
transformer they were dinosaurs
look at this dinosaur yeah there's
something like that but this is uh how
amazing like you guys literally have
opinions that nobody will have of movies
unless
you're forced to watch them over and
over and over it's the only filter you
know it's a very weird filter to like
have instilled because i worked there
for six years you work at a job every
day for six years something happens and
luke worked there for just almost as
long
three he says
it felt like a lifetime
when you work all those movies it and it
it's a groundhog day thing but also like
you learn to love certain things and
then they're you know we also had a bar
so i imagine if you walked into a
convenience store and you saw somebody
selling smokes the wrong way you'd be
like what the [ __ ] so like when we walk
into a theater and the line isn't moving
and the popcorn's not flowing we're like
what the [ __ ] i'll tell you i don't know
if i judge other clerks based on the
fact that i'm like i made a movie about
the world's worst clerks like there's no
way i could be like hey do it better
fair enough um but i did have a moment
recently in retail and i'm sorry to
snyder verse fans like come on oh we're
being buddies this is so important we'll
get back to it and trust me luke's gonna
fellate this movie so sweetly
you're gonna you're gonna be like i'm
glad we didn't have to live through that
for more than 20 minutes straight
i went to this place's vegan bakery yeah
i'm a vegan i ain't rubbing it in your
face you don't need to be vegan i do
because i had a massive heart attack a
couple years ago almost died so i
changed one plant base that's what
brings me to this lovely vegan into luca
lake called uh toluca lake cafe and
bakery all vegan
um
they sell
uh like uh i guess they'd be like um
mexican or latin
bakery treats so porquitos conchas
things that i've never been exposed to
before
where i was like what's this and they're
phenomenal
so everybody who's like in line before
me
uh they all like speak to the lady
behind the counter lovely old ladies a
family run shot
and uh you know they're going like uh
you know uh
10 porquitos and stuff like they're not
they're
white as me
but
they had four years of spanish
so they're ordering like
in in spanish
even though everything is in english so
you know i'm like i guess that's being
considerate whatever or being
pretentious i don't know
so i watch this lady and she's [ __ ]
like ordering a bunch of [ __ ] and you
know lady behind the counter this older
lady she has to get everything
she gets the whole like order together
and uh and she wants um
uh tamales and that takes like you gotta
wrap each one individually
and you know my heart's going out to
this lady behind the counter the older
lady i'm like man like look at her look
at her go
and so she rings it all up and she
charges the lady and
you're we're on this side of the counter
and it's one of those registers where
you just put your cash right your it's
like a
you know modern thing you stick your
credit card in and [ __ ] it's facing
you which means it's facing me as well
and i literally watch this moment happen
i get judgey about it
total page comes up
and
would you like to add a tip and it
provides percentages for you to add the
tip and again i'm going to say for the
record this
elderly lady was hopping to and hustling
to put this lady who was
white as me but like busting
her high school spanish right
you know to help her out and stuff and i
ain't being granted i'm waiting but i'm
pam stoner i don't care i got nowhere to
go i'm gonna eat the [ __ ] out of this so
i got all the time in the world and i
like to watch the human dramas unfold in
front of me i'm a writer so i'm always
looking for material
so this lady puts her credit card in tip
thing comes up
and i watch her finger hover because i'm
like what is she going to tip
and it hovers right to next
so i'm like alright fair enough there's
a tip jar on the counter maybe she's
going to do it in cash that's nice of
you
got to be gotta be she's got cash on her
and she doesn't want to put it on the
credit card but this is picking up for a
corporation or something [ __ ]
she picks up her [ __ ] gear and she
walks out
now
i'm pretty sure i saw what i saw but i
don't want to go accusing people so the
lady behind the counter goes can i help
you i said yes
did that lady tip
and she goes what and i was like did
that lady tip she goes yeah and i was
like are you sure i don't think she
tipped
and she looked at the casper and she
goes no i was like i knew it and i went
to the door open the door
and yell out in the parking lot
no tip
and the lady is putting the stuff in her
car and she goes what and we're all
wearing masquerade so she comes back to
the store and i was like
you didn't tip
and she was like
yeah i did i was like no you didn't
and this lady hopped too
she's going no i tipped and i was like
you didn't but whatever and i tipped for
her instead i was like i'll tip for you
and she goes thanks oh my god and
[ __ ] after she left for sure i said
to leila like let's be sure like because
then her son came out and stuff i was
like did she tip because like i would
have been mortified if like right i was
the [ __ ] right but no okay
now you know some people out there like
hey man not everyone can afford to tip
number one
even if you give a buck a buck is a tip
number two
she got into a [ __ ] mercedes she
could have tipped she'd want enough
[ __ ] [ __ ]
she could have tipped
um but to lie about it like
i don't know pretty greasy if you're
gonna if you leave trash on the floor of
a theater now me and jake are gonna come
and be like what the [ __ ] you know you
know how we're here to talk about zack
snyder's justice league well you just
heard kev smith's justice league
justice
dawn of justice man i was like no tip
that's like batman taking out the tower
you know what i'm saying voice was
modulated
and i chose batman so as to not be one
of the god characters i'm the mortal
amongst guys i like standing shoulder
shoulder
let's get back to zack snyder's justice
it writes itself it really does
and easily shootable
one location yeah man we're out we don't
need four hours
we were out that exchange was done but
yeah
yeah that's a short film i could put
behind a 99 pay wall on amazon very good
or win awards in japan
exactly excellent final draft you can
see it but i am typing
right in front of us
um
how excited
were you where were you on the spectrum
of release the snyder are you a social
media kid either of yous were you guys
involved with that or you're like that's
not for me that's for other people i had
so much respect for the movement okay
i probably signed a petition or two i do
that every now and then for stuff i
believe in the globetrotters wanted to
join the nba as a regular franchise and
i signed the [ __ ] petition like i
like things well done you know what i
mean so like i probably signed a
petition here there but i i didn't
you know like as much as i believed in
zack snyder as much as i believed in man
of steel and batman i didn't believe
that such a thing could happen where
you're not alone a studio would would i
don't know stand down and and they
didn't they're smart like wb is genius
they made
almost a billion dollars on the first
cut in theater they gave a little loot
to make this one and then they've made a
bunch of dough probably on hbo max and
subscribers and stuff if nothing else
i mean they ate their cake had it ate it
again like so like they're doing fine
too
but i just didn't believe it would go
down so i thought like just blown away
vindicated like couldn't couldn't
believe it i i don't know i'm sure you
can go back and listen to old episodes
fat man beyond um but i too
like i was all for it my thing was
always like let him do his [ __ ]
movies like now that we've seen one of
his movies interrupted please
let him do his [ __ ] thing because at
least his thing is his flavor
whereas you just gave us this [ __ ]
milkshake that's his flavor and some
other [ __ ] and [ __ ] it just ain't
tasty at all i'd rather just watch what
he had in mind and
to say that zack snyder's justice league
is a different movie from justice league
is to say that like you know
uh
my dick is different than my wife's dick
like they're almost incomparable right
it's like it's not coke and pepsi dude
it's like really smoking like milk and
you would think they are based on the
fact like well come on [ __ ] so much
of it
is the other movie how how different can
they be it's not even coke and milk it's
like a two liter of coke and a hershey's
kiss i agree you know what i mean like
it's like bizarre we watched the the
justice league the original cut how down
was i in a family show at the theater we
were waiting you know uh part of the
reason why it came out in theaters yeah
we did like a midnight perk of the
like the wednesday night before things
came out we could test the movie or
whatever and we watch it late at night
which luke was just watching the movie
but
i was watching it too but it's also like
you know if we
sell out a theater with our friends for
endgame you know that shit's going to be
crazy right you know um a lot of the
movies we were just watching because
like we had a bug up our ass and thought
it would be fun to watch um but things
like the marvel movies we really like to
watch just to see like how serious is
this really gonna be and um you could
usually judge pretty good and justice
league was rough that was a rough watch
even for you were you a fan going in
were you like i can't wait yeah i mean
absolutely because like i had spent i'd
spent all this time banging the drum on
uh on bvs wonder woman had just showed
out people loved it like i mean and it
felt like it was such a such a turn and
it felt like everything went you were um
to take it back you were a big bvs kid
oh my god so bvs
just came a little oh my god i mean dude
i started a whole podcast because of how
much i love bbs like me and my friend
katie great singer we went to film
school together as well and we have a
podcast that's like almost 100 episodes
called bad movie branch all because i
want to do one episode saying here's why
batman's superman's good and that was
like in 2017 or like 2018 like i
couldn't stop banging the drum and now
it's i don't have to bang it it's b
and to quote lex and bvs the bell's been
wrong like you know what i mean and
they've heard it
you know what i mean like
i don't know
i don't have to do [ __ ] uh snyder like
you know justice was had but at the time
yeah i was so into bbs
and i think mostly because like when
they saw it in theater i was i was like
well that was challenging i was looking
for you justice league was challenging
justice league was like i walked home
like charlie brown like
because
because like i i thought i thought it
was like okay well at the very least it
looks like it's equalizing bvs at the
very least it looks like we're on the
right trajectory wonder woman was great
and then you watch it and it just like
you know you've got the cgi mustache
opening stuff which feels
very the scene is very jaws it's not the
superman we've got it was like i like
superman saving cast materials one of my
biggest complaints about it is those
kids don't sound like kids i mean yeah
they sound like two 20 year olds
trying to sound like kids
[Laughter]
full disclosure i haven't seen that cut
of the movie since the the midnight
screening that we saw i watched it and
bought the target exclusive and watched
it more at home did you really i i like
i'm a collector you know i mean i can't
let it fall by the wayside zack still
needed my money like i um
i in terms of the justice league version
of it
um i did you think
their opening
credit sequence
was
the original opening credit sequence of
the justice league or did you did zach
intend to do
the opening that he did in zack snyder's
justice league literally pick it up from
bvs
was that the full intention or do you
think i always wonder if he saw how the
justice league opened
and he was like well i'm gonna do that
i could but he says he didn't see it at
all that's how the war goes that's how
the lord goes and i believe him too he's
a fourth [ __ ] dude like
i honestly don't feel he says one thing
and the lore says that his wife and
christopher nolan said don't [ __ ]
watch this movie which
if you're familiar with the flick like i
if now having seen his version of right
um
i that's probably the best and only
advice you could give because he too
would have been baffled like how do you
get this
out of that it's like sometimes like you
know every once in a while i'll bump
into online
some takedown in one of my movies and
i'm like how do you get that
out of what we made like really like did
i
is it me no it's the children who are
wrong exactly
but it is like it is baffling and i
imagine he would have felt
the same way but there is one moment
and i you know i don't
i don't want this to be like smith
defends justice league but i did like
um
save one person oh yeah yeah
that and i didn't know that that was him
i didn't necessarily
feel that that was
josh like that didn't scream like well i
was [ __ ] joss whedon dialogue but i
did like
save one person that felt like
that felt
batman to me for him to be like look you
know i'm dealing with a kid who's never
done it before
um i can't remember if there's anything
else
that he did that i'm like well i can
live with that like i remember when that
movie ended i was just like oh man
i mean and then they do the the race
like superman and flash through the
mid-credit race
i was like well that's comics i'm into
that exactly i liked it a lot more when
when grant melissa did it on supergirl
like years before i agreed and they were
much more charming eating their ice
cream
yeah yeah the best end credits i watched
that a lot i was happy that in credit
came back but with a better version too
like the one of lex and stuff but yeah i
mean like it felt like that was that
movie it feels like this move where it's
like
we'll try to please both crowds and
instead you have the people like my camp
who
lived and died by not only did i love
man of steel and bvs i love wonder woman
i went and saw a suicide squad three
times i dug that [ __ ] so like i was in
you're deep on this i was in i was like
why not and and don't get me wrong it's
not like i was like not into the mcu
like i believed the mcu it's just i was
happy to have another take uh and and
more options and stuff um
but like so you don't please those fans
and then they also try to like appease
the casual moviegoer but the casual
moviegoer can smell insincerity just as
much as anybody else just as much as
filmmakers too like
i can tell that i can tell where the
reshoots are happening just by the look
of people by the by the like you know i
mean i can tell
when you do as as ushers do you engage
with the audience and hear
like when you say the average guy the
average audience is that based on
conjecture is that based on i've seen
i've worked with average audiences and
they too so i'm i honestly i'm making it
up
but uh but i just i gave you the perfect
platform to be like no i sat there with
him yeah you said a lot i sat there with
like a trench coat on and like studied
what people were saying about no i i i
didn't i i just like just that's your
feeling
and when we chop it up with a lot of
people that come out of movies and like
you get even if you haven't seen a flick
i know a lot about movies i didn't see
just based on like a conglomerate of 200
people's opinion coming out and stuff
too but it's like
you know when something's off and you
know like when when you're trying to put
the the square peg in the round hole and
stuff and every now and then in that
like in that justice league it just
rears its head honestly pretty
frequently what came out when that came
out do you guys remember us dudes who
were working in the industry so aquaman
came out right after right uh am i crazy
is that the same year like it was
november justice league and the man was
like right aquaman was christmas it was
either i want to say i think it might
have been the following christmas
i know they get blurry because november
was a justice league here
and then i think aquaman was the
following was anything else was there
doctor strange
yeah doctor strange was november
22 it was right around then i believe
and then ragnarok but i think that was
before ragnarok was a couple weeks
before oh my god that's what preceded
justice yeah so here's the other thing
to remember like going back to what
we're talking about about like length
and stuff like there's also
like the just the business of like we
need a two-hour movie well these these
mcu movies are two and a half hours long
and they're sitting through the credits
so like we need to
we need to get this going and i really
do feel like there's like you said like
it is just kind of this ungodly
conglomeration where you're just making
everybody unhappy yeah um i feel like
he's so comfy on streaming now when you
say we need a two-hour movie that's the
studio the studio
no no it's the studio saying to
the theaters
we need a two-hour theater so we can get
more shows in so we can get some
turnaround going
um as far as i'm concerned because i was
always just concerned about turn around
all the time
and yeah you get an idea of like
especially at our theater because we had
to get rid of movies pretty quick into
the spider-verse stayed for seven weeks
wow you know what i mean like that's
really really good wonder woman came
back
four more weeks exactly on my screen or
all the screens oh like like one of
those you start just like on two and
then you go down to one but an average
film goes three weeks and not a very
good film is two weeks and then if you
get real if you have a black panther you
get it sometimes for a couple of months
and that's like crazy so
well i don't know like exact thoughts as
much as
spider-verse stayed for seven weeks
justice league was probably there for
three
it moved quick the reason i think it had
to be a year later is even surprising i
think like they they needed a second to
breathe and rebrand because they were
like it's not going to be like that and
like they gave them all the the new suit
and it was a different movie they did
everything kind of different batman vs
superman did not do it all at our
theater particularly
in comparison to what they want from the
marvel movies dc was just not
hitting it the same way with the
frequency the same right
that's all
so by the time
you see
zack snyder's justice league on hbo max
which uh full disclosure like i did a
um
special for for hbo home video hosted
interviewed zach you're wearing the
t-shirt zack snyder's justice league
the uh so you know and and i again i
think he's a lovely guy
but i don't say that i enjoy this movie
or i think he's talented because i know
i don't know him well enough to
be that guy
but you know facts facts i don't you
don't need me to [ __ ] tell you the
guy's talented and if you've paid
attention for the last few years because
he's fairly you know vocal now
um
you don't need me to tell you he's a
[ __ ] nice guy either but um
you know once again in interviewing him
for that special the premiere special
because it was right before it aired the
night that it ended on hbo max
uh he says just [ __ ] sweetheart such
a nice [ __ ] dude
and i don't
understand like with all the money that
they got over there
and with all the stuff that they green
light and do
just like
break off a bunch and make let him do
his own [ __ ] thing
like
let the snyder verse continue why not
like especially there in that venue
which is an incredibly safe
uh space like you don't have to
compete at the box office as they've
learned over the course of the last year
they've learned a lot you know i'm sure
with uh releasing movies day and date
on hbo max
with theaters and stuff and we saw how
that affected the matrix
the recent matrix so
you know there's
there's a there's got to be a way to
just be like
here's 100 200 million a year man do a
thing for us like do uh here your yearly
[ __ ] thing with us
why not there's enough of a audience out
there they're always like you can't
avoid it on social media like they
they live and breed they're they're not
they're not not they didn't get the
snyder cut and they were like we're
finished
you know now they're like bring us the
the david air cut of suicide squad and
release the snyder verse like keep it
going and i i'm with the kids like
why can't they just be like maybe it
could be
you know maybe zach's had enough of like
warner brothers
you know you get kicked a few times and
you're like look i can go to netflix
they'll give me [ __ ] better money i
can do whatever [ __ ] i want launch car
blind like you know all i have to do is
that thing all i have to do is let go of
their toys
right which i you know admittedly he put
a lot of time into their toys but
there's happiness and also letting it go
apparently because he went over to
netflix and seemed to have a blast
but
if i'm hbo if i'm hbo max if i'm warner
brothers man like i'd be like
let's find a way to make this work man
they ain't got to be theatrical maybe
maybe it's just like once a year like
come on somebody's [ __ ] straight to
hbo max
movies look expensive and cost money
like [ __ ] i watch ridley scott made
raised by wolves that [ __ ] looks
expensive son
give that kind of money to zach to do
a thing a five five hour thing in the dc
universe the snyder verse i have a
question for you gentlemen
with the advent of
the two spider-man movies and they're
multiverses doctor strange now coming
out the flash now coming out do you
think you're gonna be so turgid just
saying
well it sounds you know the one thing
i've been saying about this new
spider-man movie is that it's the most
brilliant piece of housekeeping i've
ever seen in a movie ever in my life
um every loose end from every spider-man
movie was not only tied up but then
turned on its head so that we all feel
better about ourselves
in addition to the films that have
already been efficient the climate we're
in now as opposed to the climate came
out once of course you killed a villain
in the end clean as [ __ ] and it was
really really nice to watch it's just a
great movie across the board for
somebody who is kind of whatever about
uh superhero movies in general like that
was it was i really really really really
liked it um
uh but i do want to know with all of
this stuff happening do you think that
if the money is there like if it all
makes sense and now multiverses are a
thing
why not let zack snyder do his thing
maybe that was just because we have one
batman at a time and now that we can
have as many batman every time
yeah they clearly don't feel that way
anymore like
i i think there are enough there was a
time
when hey we're mate we're warner
brothers and we make motion pictures
and you know [ __ ] batman on tv what
are you [ __ ] nuts that's for cartoons
and [ __ ]
you know now
they're like [ __ ] yeah we'll do batman
on tv like we're doing the we're doing a
penguin show right [ __ ] silly if you
don't think a batman appearance is not
somewhere in the cards for it
they're doing a gotham central show i
think yeah how does he not show up
[ __ ] there they're certainly building
out the universe the gotham universe and
stuff
so
that's with their current incarnation
that's just off of the batman right
clearly they're willing to spend money
on this sort of thing
um nope it sounds like there's no plans
although he tweeted something or being
in tweet or whatever he his social media
thing is
somebody
said should we give up hope
and he like [ __ ] wrote never give up
hope or something like that
um and at one point tweeted a picture
which could indicate like you know a
a um
another
dc project so i don't know for all we
know maybe that discussion is happening
i'm just saying like if i was in charge
oh my god i feel like it's dumb money to
just give this this guy not dumb it's
dumb not to give this guy smart money
not to give this guy a chunk of change
and keep this [ __ ] thing going
they're letting like james gunn is
keeping squad going right now
with the peacemaker right and that show
a looks wonderful but b does not
necessarily look cheap granted zach's
stuff
takes a lot more time than it looks like
i ain't dismissing james gun [ __ ] it's
beautiful this squad's a beautiful movie
but fish yeah i'm from [ __ ]
gigantic but he wrote every episode too
yeah of this yeah it's pretty cool but
it looks like and this ain't me being
dismissive i can't wait to watch it but
like there's a budget there yeah sure i
don't know if zach could work in that
budget based on what he likes to do his
[ __ ] is again he paints in [ __ ]
in splash pages man makes blockbuster
like james works dialogue you know and
it's not like he's not great at visuals
he's great at that too but
you know he'll make a [ __ ]
uncut two-minute [ __ ] take of
peacemaker
bickering with
vigilante
work and be funny
um zach you know zach's stuff there's
some levity or humor there but funny is
not what you think of and it's like and
it's also time consuming like it takes
time
to make all them slow-mo shots like if
you're doing an hour-long series
you know that's 20 minutes of
slow-mo shots right there alone they're
beautiful but they they take some time
but it's not like it can't be done it's
like just let them shoot another [ __ ]
five-hour movie chop it up like bait
and [ __ ] watch the fish you come eat
it man like you track them [ __ ]
sharks
the one i mean the analogy falls apart
but you know what i'm talking about
it's all about the subscriber game these
guys are chasing 100 million right now
they're at 70 something
you know i guess they could know more
than us i'm sure there are people out
there going well [ __ ] if it would
have made sense they would have [ __ ]
made the offer by now they got the
algorithm they know
i don't know like i feels like that
movement's only gotten bigger well an
hbo max is just big man like batgirl is
is gonna be [ __ ] huge that's a series
or a movie it's the flick right and
they've confirmed that is it for them it
ain't even for i think it's for them
yeah i remember confirmed to be in it
yeah after being in the flashlight it
will not be exhibited uh uh you know
what i mean
i think so that's
i
unless i'm misunderstanding i love that
question yes when i said it with
authority i was like listen
he knows that exhibited was so hard i
was like it needs to be more it was a
little british it will not be exhibited
it will not be exhibited
it's an hbo max only venture so they're
going hard
that plus like like you said like a few
days from now we're not going to awesome
i'm gonna we should really adapt that
more adopt that more than
than [ __ ] like is it in theaters like
is it gonna be exhibited is it not being
exhibited it does make it sound like
feel like it's like clerks three be
exhibited
if there's people still alive after this
i used to tell people i was in
exhibition and distribution i like to
say that kind of [ __ ] true it's part
of the business and you talk about
omicron and stuff too but like could
this age and it's a terrible it's a
terrible circumstance to have like
hbo max thrive on it but it's true it's
like like
zack snyder's justice league is going to
be part of the the 2020 coveted time
capsule yeah and like all of this also
one of the most important comic book
movies
honestly ever made i don't even say that
with like it's a hint of irony it's
when you think of comic book movies it's
a now it's epic it's an opera it's got a
damarang
um and it's also insanely memorable
because of how it came to be
how it almost didn't
happen and then
existed first there was a mountain then
there was no mountain then there is
to borrow from donovan uh let us
let us dive into finally
your take as a fan when you watched
the
zack snyder's justice league
uh i mean i think i've said the word
vindication so many times during this
episode but it's that like more than
anything like the fact that i was seeing
it was one thing and like it it only had
to deliver in that it existed right like
i was just so happy that we were here at
this point but instead it's like
not only did this it's like you're
talking about not only did this movie
exist like not only was the story there
and just like thrown to the side but
like like
a lot of story and like found a way to
make a cyborg origin film within a flick
found a way to do the aquaman origin
movie before the aquaman origin but we
didn't you know we didn't know that till
after the fact uh found a way to um
found a way to do a full-on flash origin
movie you know what i mean like and all
the while
giving us a full-on steppenwolf origin
like like when you say all these things
out loud the fact that it is only four
hours is mind-blowing and i think part
of that is because you know originally
he wanted to do two flicks right i think
there was like this huge like i've seen
this huge like artistic piece of what
the snyder verse was supposed to look
like or whatever and it it looks it
literally looks like something like
would draw up after being like imbued by
kryptonian knowledge like it's like he
had something going he was trying to
play chess instead of checkers and and
that's all good um
but like you watch this movie and i was
like overwhelmed by like not only how
much
i enjoyed
all of those like new characters not
only by how much i enjoyed the stuff
they put in and fleshed out but just the
fact that like you're talking about it
it's it's a triumph it's a it's a
feeling of like
somebody got to succeed somebody got a
moment somebody got to like
put it all out there and not only be
like not only get the opportunity but be
applauded for it and the fact that this
stands symbolically in the face of like
zach coming back and finishing this
movie after the personal tragedy
suffered he doesn't like he doesn't
leave that movie for like anyway ends
with dedication that's what i'm saying
and then plays that plays her song over
the credits you know it's beautiful that
was her favorite song he mentioned and
stuff uh he said it like when he was
talking to you on the on the precursor
to it dropping and stuff like what what
the movie
symbolizes and how when he went back
through it he like cut it with
uh suicide prevention like awareness in
mind and stuff and you see the ad and
the flick for it and like
it just feels so
cathartic there's that there's that
layer that it has it's a movie of
catharsis and and and i think it it
speaks loudest when it's through
characters like
getting over like a lot a lot a lot of
baggage and pain and they all are
barry's got a dad in prison cyborg's mom
was killed he should have died his dad
did this very complicated aquaman's on
the outs with his family batman's batman
he's pretty damn moody like everybody's
everybody's going through all this like
personal tragedy and it just plays
insanely thematic with what was going on
in the united states what went on with
zach and so
basically you just had to lay this one
up and i said this about spiderman too
but they just [ __ ] dunked it
it just felt like the universe can heal
now snyder got to tell a story and
i feel like
in both color and black and white i know
i was watching justice's gray today did
you ever watch logan in black and white
no recommend it like i highly recommend
it and just this is gray i mean this is
a movie that is meant to just throw it
on and be watching chapters if you feel
like it i recommend that too it looks
really nice and monochrome dude and
justice is close yeah yeah exactly
exactly i do think it's interesting um
that not only is it in black and white
but then the whole movie is in 4-3 as
well yeah um which i've i did that with
the other one too the uh zack snyder's
justice league the color version yeah is
awesome yeah both of them are in 443 i
was wondering if that was a way to save
money
no
uh i think
for him he shot 4-3
um because he shot for
imax oh
okay okay which he did uh he said his
rationale was
you know you can't get him head to toe
in a
2-3-3 frame without pulling away the
[ __ ] back and then they shrink and don't
look nearly as dramatic he's like look i
can line them all up
drop the crane down and get this really
heroic shot if it's
the 133 frame so
it was in bvs if you remember
the opening was
um
imax the whole opening sequence and then
when the movie proper began
it went to like two three three he did a
nolan kind of thing remember nolan
opened with [ __ ] imax on
dark knight
um
so uh
yeah it he
by by doing he framed for this okay
whole [ __ ] things composed for for
133 for imax
and
getting it to 233 is a pain in the ass
like something
an extra [ __ ] step right so it's
actually easier
to be like great let's figure out how
we're going to [ __ ] map this that's
been a question since it's since they
released it that's my my guess i just
assumed i mean that makes the most sense
i just assumed like oh we're putting 70
million dollars into a four-hour r-rated
batman movie let's not animate the edges
that's adorable i mean
to like we can't if we put this much
money in
afford the black bars
well i'm just being like man if i if i
shot a football game i'd probably just
put people in the stands and then like
they showed the way they shot the
football sequence with cyborg and stuff
and it's like all green like not like
not even like real terrorists like i'm
like it's so stylized like everything to
say the least most of his stuff all of
this stuff's incredibly stylized even
even uh conversation shots just dialogue
scenes yeah like where nothing you know
[ __ ] splash pages happen
happening it's still very stylized but
that [ __ ] football game is stunning
it was something like i don't even like
sports and i was like that's [ __ ]
beautiful i do like sports and he's down
to the detail because i'm sitting there
football big time football so you like
that sequence i love that sequence and
i'm watching it with my wife and i'm
like
why is it gotham versus a real team i'm
like why is it wisconsin i'm like is it
because they're both under armour
schools i know under armour's got a
thing with wb and then i'm like google
and i'm like oh zack's from wisconsin so
it's like everything he does dude is
like
there's a choice there's it's true this
isn't just happening you know what i
mean and i think that's maybe the reason
i respond to it so much like like even
like if yes these are iconic characters
that a lot of people could consider not
to be trifled with or whatever but if
zach's like if zach does it he goes all
in and i i respect a man who makes a
choice no wishy-washiness about it like
this is my flavor that's so nice um and
every filmmaker um you know uh
throws in easter eggs like that like uh
when they've got an opportunity if they
give a [ __ ] that's how you could tell
they care
uh watts does it with uh spiderman they
throw it in license plates right like
he's always hiding
the a character's first appearance
number and a license plate i think
recently it was stan lee's birthday he
hid that's actually the license plate on
the on the on the big freeway scene
spoilers i don't know when you yelled
out by the internet come on
they made a billion and a half
somebody you guys have seen it
um you were he talked you into watching
it jake yeah i mean i've been wanting to
watch it but he has a beautiful tv i
wasn't gonna watch it on my phone you
went to his place for [ __ ] four hours
and sat there i was sitting his hats
yeah i'll smoke some weed and watch
justice league it's okay
and you're not busy and to be fair it
took me two days to watch it i crashed
after two hours turned it back on
because i thought i missed the whole
nightmare sequence i was texting luke
with 10 minutes left in the movie being
like did i sleep through this thing he's
like just watch the [ __ ] movie i know
i started like shooting lines at you i'm
like you said you watched it he's like
so close to the end um
i you know i i have to say
the same as luke there's nothing i
appreciate more than a choice and let me
tell you something if you have an r
rated 4-3 batman movie that's four hours
long choice did they write that r
i don't know but it's
i think there are two ultimate bvs is r
and then i think the snyder cup might
all it would have been well they would
have don't have to write it right
because it was you're right there was no
it was not exhibited
[Laughter]
um yeah so maybe i don't know if they
rated it but i guess well they still
decap there's a couple of frogs it's
there's some hardcore well they
decapitate a monster you can get away
with that i mean it's a it's a i guess
that's another conversation to have as
well because uh he's a new god for
heaven's sakes
we were watching um
we watched kids leave infinity war
and that was that was hard what do you
mean like uh
this might i might be diverting too much
but um
you know like you p everyone go sees
everyone goes to see these superhero
movies and it's a big family kind of
thing to do
and so we worked infinity war and at the
end of infinity war spoiler alert half
of them die
and so there were children coming out
being like what happened to spider-man
and again it gets it
gets to me that's all
um
they were they were like looking for
answers from you and you're like i or
just like straight up leaving early in
tears because it's not
because it's it's it
some people think it's supposed to be a
kids movie and it's actually very very
serious you know sure yeah and so that's
how i feel about this justice league i
mean this is an adult film you take your
yes in many ways this is the movie we
dreamed about when i was a kid yeah
before we've got tim burton's batman and
even after we got tim burton's batman
which was a
also like a [ __ ] revolutionary film
and a triumph of in many ways of style
and bringing a tone you got to remember
a previous batman was you know adam west
[ __ ] about burt ward and
camping stuff and suddenly it's like oh
my god this is kind of like the comics
and [ __ ] and he's a little more killy
but whatever the [ __ ]
so
there was um
i forget why i brought that up what was
the
point just different um
people go to see these movies for
different reasons oh yeah grown up yeah
we thought that [ __ ] was growing up in
89 and it still played the kids right it
was a huge kids movie as well
but jesus this this is the movie we
dreamed about when i was younger like oh
what if they made a [ __ ] version
where he just like [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
out of people like that [ __ ] sequence
where he like takes all those [ __ ]
out in bvs is one of the greatest batman
sequences ever committed to [ __ ] film
um it looks
like you feel frank miller's batman is
like oh it was
insane insanely well done
i i like that i'll take it there's lots
of room for lots of different flavors
they can do another version of batman
that's a little more kid-friendly and
[ __ ] but
this is what we dreamed about when we
were younger like could you imagine if
somebody treated it so [ __ ] seriously
there was no looking down the nose at it
there was no like joke about like yeah
what do you want us to wear brown
spandex or yellow spandex like holy
rusted metal batman yeah
i'm all for ride comments and whatnot
but just like
treat it with like [ __ ] such insane
respect and
that's what he does they're so [ __ ]
serious and he treats him with so much
respect
um here's my question to you
and it's a little like [ __ ] buzzfeedy
i like buzzfeed
where would you you know it's it's along
the lines of uh
uh
drowning or eaten by a shark
so you know which way you got to pick a
way to die you're gonna drown you're
getting eaten by the shark
how fast you get eat by the shark i
can't give you those answers is that the
that's the actual question yeah oh i
thought you were like anything more than
that
here's the example that's so funny
drowning or getting by
uh definitely get eaten
really i would hate the drought they say
that you know who knows but they say
that drowning is one of the most
peaceful ways to die is that right i
don't know dude one time when i was a
kid getting in by a shark [ __ ]
that number one hurts number two
like really hurts number three the final
moments of your life are in [ __ ]
agony in the mouth
of a super predator i'm so prepared
you lucas guy taylor filmmaker on
[ __ ] amazon
loses his life to just be something
else's eventual [ __ ] he eats you and
it's not like he's not like he kills you
and he wears your skull forever where
he's like i killed a man from above and
i was a champion and [ __ ] this will
show the landlubbers
you were one of a hundred [ __ ] things
he's gonna eat that month and then he
just [ __ ] crapped you out in the sea
you
a little miracle of a human being taylor
taylor's love becoming fish poop choose
drowning always choose right i'm gonna i
guys i i think i'd rather drown
i gotta i gotta be honest with you i
i've thought about it not for nothing
but if you drown and die and your body's
down there why are you not still
fighting they're catching you fast
you're getting drown in a lake there
ain't no
for certain i suppose but it doesn't
it's true it doesn't seem peaceful i it
sounds [ __ ] terrifying
come on [ __ ] what sounds more
terrifying i can't get aaron to me i
this is crazy or
this thing is eating me a lot wow
holy [ __ ] i'm just ahead now but i'm
still alive have you ever had a panic
attack it's like the same thing
i haven't like three times a day at this
point i want to give you my [ __ ]
shark kevin it's like all right
no uh but i think that like look dude
how many people drown a year i'd love to
see the number jake google it
and it's like but how many people get
eaten by a shark it's like so at least
then i'm like a pretty cool statistic
the more important uh thing is that's
just to set you up just to give you a
frame for the real question okay good
do you have to either live in
uh zack snyder's metropolis
like close to the daily planet
or
the marvel universe
at the end of infinity war
now i'm not going to say that you're
dying
in zack snyder's metropolis
my [ __ ] didn't work out for a lot of
those people it looked like you could
have been out of town you might have
been in [ __ ] chicago visiting some
people and stuff so maybe you escaped it
but you definitely lost your [ __ ]
whereas the marvel universe you're
pulled out for five [ __ ] years and
you have to come back into a world you
know how difficult it was to get your
first films made yeah you get blipped
okay uh you get snapped [ __ ] that blip
[ __ ] that's what they call it
took isn't it well it makes sense for
them they didn't know it was a snap but
we all saw it so we know it was the sky
it makes sense i kind of dig it
so
you're faking me out man
you're shaking me left and right
you're getting snapped out of existence
for five years and think about how hard
it was to get your movies on amazon
prime back then yeah
five years from now you've lost a step
or two
um [ __ ] people have gone on with
their lives left you behind taylor
taylor became taylor something else got
a little less chat
less saturated oh yeah all of us but you
missed his [ __ ] zack snyder's justice
league however the good news is when you
come back you do have that to look
forward well that's good as the rest of
your life is falling apart you're like
well at least i'm desperate
[ __ ] worked out for him
um which are you picking zack snyder's
metropolis circa man of steel
or
uh
anywhere in the marvel universe circa
the end of infinity war
uh uh i took a snap i'm answering mcu
and here's why is because like
even though like alien
like invasions and [ __ ] like that have
become routine in that universe and
stuff
there's jokes there there's some bright
colors and stuff like that i love
the snider verse i don't want to live in
the snyder verse man like that's things
are very life and death and it reminds
me a lot of like church
and like like you know i mean like like
and honestly it's probably that on a
poster it reminds me a lot of dot dot
church it's like oh man we are going to
have to answer for for our our
short comings in this life that's how
snyder
feels like you don't even like at worst
like yeah i got blipped and yeah
taylor's married somebody else that's a
bummer but like i we could have like
ant-man's like buddy recount the last
five years to me and stuff like that i'd
have a blog
alone yeah to have it told you in that
quick [ __ ] fun uh i'm gonna call it
the peyton reed style i like it yeah
because that's who's responsible for him
i know everyone wants to give uh oh it's
michael pina credit well performed i
ain't taking anything away but let's be
honest
it begins with the word
and the word was paid read i'ma bring it
on boy
we're all breaking
let's be honest
um the uh closing thoughts
on zack snyder's justice league
gentlemen uh
an event
uh so big
that uh it's probably up there with
um
infinity war which is saying a lot
because it took [ __ ] marvel 10 years
to get to infinity war but like
this became
such an insanely talked about
event
and we're not comparing quality or
anything like that but as big
as that movie in terms of like where
it's what kind of [ __ ]
how much movement on the pop culture
needle
um a seismic event of that's
that uh type made
closing thoughts gentlemen starting with
you jake
i
we just sounded so [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
luke can i talk about how this is like a
uh an easter movie and it reminds me
well we joke about the whole
resurrection thing luke will get more
into that for me when i was watching it
i got this vibe of like when i was a kid
and watching the 10 commandments and i
was like how cool is it that instead of
doing cecil b demille's like epic
biblical features we have four hour
batman movies that are in slow motion
and like i mean i didn't get to talk
about how cool the story was like i love
cyborg i love like all like the story
that he told is really cool and also i
think it's kind of [ __ ] up that he
told a four-hour movie and still
there's still room
so much unanswered there's still like
sequels and sequels to be made like we
were talking about before so uh as is
often the case with auteur driven film
so many people uh get left off of the
credit list but a lot of credit's got
got to go to chris tario as well sure i
mean um
a gentleman no slouch himself who holds
an academy award for the screenplay to
argo um and has worked on a star wars
thing as well i met him on the set of a
star wars thing lovely lovely guy he
knows what he's doing yeah yeah
a thing or two about a thing or two um
he didn't get sung out enough there is
uh in that four hour cut i want to know
how long that script was
like literally script page count what do
you has got to be 300 pages i mean
without a doubt if it's a four hour
final cut what was the rough well again
i say three hours because that four-hour
final cut a lot of that
is slow-mo that's a good thing
and
you know action sequences which on a
script page
uh let's say you know [ __ ] um
the big last [ __ ] fight
you know uh as
as you know dad is happening
lasts five to ten pages that's a [ __ ]
half an hour of that right totally so it
you know he has a way of extending time
in a beautiful way i wouldn't change
anything but that [ __ ] one of the
greatest comic book sequences ever
committed to film
um is uh the flash meets iris and
[ __ ] saves her from a simple car
wreck
[ __ ] stunning watching him turn and
his sneakers explode
um you know we've seen time we've seen
barry and speed
represented in many different forms uh
and you know on [ __ ] cw for a long
time i was there i know how they do it
um we've seen it in uh uh you know
quicksilver and uh
paige voltron
we've seen quicksilver in the x-men
movie future past right um
uh so
you know
if you're gonna step up and be like hey
now i'm gonna do
my version of that
it better impress and that sequence
impresses the [ __ ] he has a beautiful
use of music throughout that entire
movie
once again
that i believe the hbo max
zack snyder
zack snyder's justice league cut
got away with in a world where the
theatrical version might not have oh i
never i didn't even think about it oh
come on a studio being like we need hits
man like i don't know about all this
slow you know [ __ ] moody music you
know we got a [ __ ] ariana grande song
or whatever the [ __ ] or i mean for all i
know
the soundtrack to the first um suicide
squad where they they destroyed his
movie and that all of it is just needle
dropping
music video you're telling me every
young kid's ringtone isn't the
the song the villagers sing as aquaman
swims away magic moment that's when you
know
you're you're dealing with a filmmaker
who's like oh i'm treating this very
seriously dude it's like it's like when
she whales giving the chris knife and
dune i'm like oh they're taking this
[ __ ] seriously when she sniffs a sweater
i'm like that rocks um one of my beefs
with the movie though is that [ __ ] so
many people are like bruce wayne
i'm like what
one of the most famous [ __ ] human
beings on the planet i mean granted
they're in the far reaches of iceland or
whatever sure uh but then there's
somebody oh [ __ ] barry allen is like
uh why is this a guy i've never met
which i guess is not the same no he
indicates that he don't even know who
bruce wayne is right
right he gets right he's like oh you're
batman yeah that he's actually he's like
oh but he's never heard of or seen bruce
yeah that is very very strange uh
especially because they kind of
establish in bvs that he's like
especially because in that world they
throw his identity around like [ __ ]
you know they don't care yeah oh my god
by the end of the movie spoilers you got
[ __ ] lex luthor giving it up
to [ __ ] uh deathstroke and [ __ ]
you're like god damn it everybody knows
who he is no wonder
like the next iteration had to take
place in a dystopian future
where he's like look everybody knew what
happens is everybody finds out who
batman is and [ __ ] goes real bad real
quick
um back to you captain
that's pretty much all i have to say
other than i'm dying to see the
nightmare movie i've been waiting for i
don't know why there isn't i mean maybe
you guys have like an actual answer for
that like why there shouldn't be a
nightmare film
it's
just
hbo max going like oh my god give him a
whole series called nightmare
um and let him tell that whole story i'm
so fascinated by just like out of the
four hour movie there's [ __ ] six
minutes where i'm just like
you're blowing my [ __ ] away and then it
connects to bvs as well how well do you
remember man of steel i mean this guy
loves a nightmare like even a man of
steel he's got like the nightmare
sequence where like where like he's in
like the pile of bones and he's wearing
the black suit and stuff like the snider
was like [ __ ] trying to like that
look if that don't look like a combo
cover nothing doesn't seem [ __ ] being
pulled down into those skulls
it's badass man and also to be fair
revolutionary and as much as generally
speaking people don't put superman next
to skulls that's a batman kind of thing
totally so the [ __ ] juxtaposition of
him with a [ __ ] like pile of skulls i
thought was really [ __ ] metal
and again it's like a guy a lot of
people like you don't understand
superman but i'm like he's just got a
different take
and uh
and that is a [ __ ] stunning image
when i think about it it's great yeah
it's so weird like
you're dealing in fantasy already right
like [ __ ] you're dealing in the
unreal these characters get to do things
that most people can't and will never be
able to do
and yet still
there's a
you know concerted effort to be like
there's an inner life
like what if imagine if all [ __ ]
things imagine if yeah but you're taking
time to do imagine if within the imagine
if a kind of inception if you will
totally setting yourself up for here i
got a pitch for you
so he does nightmare has a [ __ ]
five to 10 episode limited series on hbo
max
and it's zack snyder
how does he not get
everybody back
i i'm not conjecturing here
or i'm conjecturing here
and without naming names
who don't come back for that you know
what i'm saying
they all love them
like all of them love zach
so
that's another reason because right now
you know
there's folks feel that
some cats like some folks feel that like
henry cavill's being
like you know
kept away from superman
and ben has recently stated that he's
like i don't want to do it anymore it
wasn't fun for me
um particularly and he cites like the
justice league
um
experience
but he loves zach and like if you were
like hey man we're going to do this he
came back already
to do a bit of the nightmare sequence
all that stuff was brand new including
him talking to the martian manhunter
so you know
i'm just saying like
it sounds like everything's like an easy
way to [ __ ] get the band back
together right i know cyborg would be
down like a clown the ray fisher man
like he's but he he seems like the
person that had the most to gain from
like the snyder cut and he's set up in
there too i'd like for it for
the nightmare world absolutely and i
mean i don't know
i've never had a discussion with him
about it but like
i wonder like the way it was shot i
wonder what that sequence cost
like on this next that obviously was
shot
more recently
that ps sequence
you know shoot the whole [ __ ] way bro
they they don't even have to be an
action sequence you can literally just
have those characters dressed that way
yes
talking to each other oh yeah about
dying walking through sign me up on
their way up you know what i watched
many seasons of the walking dead
and that's what they all did it was the
walking life too because there was a lot
of walking on that show there's a lot of
we're going to this place yeah now that
we're here some shit's going to happen i
will happily watch
that bunch of people
walking to wherever the [ __ ] they're
going and the conversations they have
which
is an inexpensive show
but that's you know the kevin smith
version but i i want zack snyder hbo are
you listening no i mean with without a
doubt man like like literally
low-hanging fruit man i'm sure these
discussions have been held before the
corridors of power but
how do you not like it just seems like a
recipe for when
um
and it does seem like a recipe for like
you know
bringing the band back together oh
without it i mean i'd be there with
bells on and
dude put everybody in costume and have
them talk like everybody talks about
daredevil for the hallway scene but
there's that episode in season two where
punisher just got him chained to the
rooftop that episode's stunning let's
just listen to him chat man let's talk
let's talk about life or death scenarios
there's a there's a book that i'm
writing my comic that i'm writing right
now that um like we were starting this
issue and was gonna have this big action
sequence and i was like you know what
like
really what's needed here is a villain
and hero
need to meet and have a long
conversation
hell yeah and that was uh you know more
than like you know we got pages and
pages of [ __ ] fighting and [ __ ]
action and stuff but like this just felt
like let's just
slow [ __ ] down for a good old fashion
you know what's going to happen here
your heat moment your true romance got
me monologuing you know
and that's my speed man so i you give me
[ __ ] you know zack snyder's nightmare
and it's just you know basically cosplay
conversations with famous people
who i'm hey you got me but i'm already a
subscriber but who don't [ __ ] join in
that mandalorian set yeah why not the
big uh what is it the volume yeah shoot
against the volume like
whatever he did like it's it's very
treated and and what not like
i'm i'm not saying that's cheap you
could [ __ ] do it yourself but it
doesn't look
costly particularly if you're not making
big action secrets like the most
expensive expensive aspect of that
felt like when they did the
shots of you know the spaceships and
then anybody that needed a like a
costume like you know uh [ __ ] um
yeah
cyborg and also flash had a bit of a did
you call oh he's got that bvs
so
you know there's so then there's some
money there on the effects but other
than that
you know
you got ben in the nightmare batman
costume we got [ __ ] leto literally
just wearing
like you know some green in his hair
what are you worried about
out of focus focus and i will i don't
give a [ __ ] i'll watch
a version of that maybe make it a half
an hour week maybe it's not now i'll
take an episode just let it helping me
figure out is he kidding about the reach
around
like no line is stuck outside look i'm
more fascinated by look
as much as that line got me intrigued i
was like what is that all about
especially because they cut to ben and
ben looks at him
in this way where you're like there
don't tell people we do that or yeah
they are there is it an exact choice or
a ban choice i think that's exact choice
i think he's like let's give him a
neutral reaction to that don't give him
a like roll eyes or something like that
or [ __ ] you it's like let's give him a
neutral reaction but i do feel like um
[Music]
i
i want to know why the joker's the key
that is very strange well i'm like this
guy was he [ __ ] what abilities he
have what does he know like they're
setting up for a [ __ ] version of the
story that i
am intrigued by and he references
like timeline
the joker does he says something about
like how many timelines or something
like yeah
indicating multiverse totally so like
there's no reason this doesn't pay off
in the flash movie if we're opening up
and there's seven different batman and
stuff like that
at the end of bvs the extended
version doesn't flash like
flash pops out of something
i'm too early let me [ __ ] your head up
it's not at the end it's in the middle
of it
it's like right in the middle of this
movie that's what i was seemingly
nothing to do with it this movie would
kind of wrap up yeah that was left over
they at least ignore the third movie if
they were ever gonna do the third like a
justice league was meant to be a
two-part movie and it's not even this as
the two-part movie this was meant to be
part one
first movie part one and two and then do
another
movie as the [ __ ] third movie or
whatever and in that movie
they were gonna they're building to to
that i feel like they've been flirting
with injustice for like a decade like
they want to do that storyline so bad
but nobody will pull the live-action
trigger well i look i i think he wants
to do that story
and i bet you dc or warner brothers
historically pre-hbo max and again
that's the big factor here
pre-hbo max there's one way
for them to be in the zack snyder
business
make a giant ass [ __ ] movie now
there's another way where it's like you
can make a giant ass series
but it feeds this machine
and you know what this costs and what
your algorithm is and what you can spend
and what it's going to attract and blah
blah
and you can keep the story
going so
i you know i don't know it's always easy
from the
from the cheap seats so i was like just
do what we want well
disney plus did real deal shows this
year with real deal marvel heroes and
like spent real deal money they look
like movies just long ass movies cut up
if they if they're doing that who's to
say i mean everybody's the future right
that's where it's headed everyone for
years has been like the futures movies
on tv and you're gonna stream the movies
right and it's like no the future is
like but we're living in it right now
where they're like we're gonna give you
a marvel movie spread out over six seven
weeks we're gonna give you you know
[ __ ] uh uh penguin series that
precedes or comes after the batman or
guest comes after that's going to keep
you around because we know we're coming
back for another the batman right sooner
or later uh we've got a peacemaker
series that's unbelievable days away you
know based on uh the movie we just saw
come out in the summertime like it's
crazy like the world we live in the
choices they give us i always talk about
what a great time to be alive
as a fanboy as a person who grew up
reading these things in the pages and
then watching them come to life
that's why i'll take as many iterations
possible
um and also that goes the other way too
i took some heat online for being like
uh you know look ben doesn't want to do
the movies anymore so in that world it
makes sense that they turn to michael
keaton he's their established batman and
also they're trying to do an older
batman so they could do a batman beyond
thing but in bat girl please and you
know and some people were like what the
[ __ ] he did you know
keaton dick sucker look you can love the
snide verse and still love
[ __ ] michael keaton as batman too
like
there are many different there's many
batman's in the world many batman's with
one batman in the world one batman with
many faces kids
and so you know that batman is a face
that
pre-existed but also like fits nicely
they're not replacing ben with michael
keaton just the way they didn't replace
michael keaton with [ __ ] ben
ben has made it clear that he's just
like yeah i'm done and they're like okay
in a world where we want to go forward
with a older batman bam
we got this this is amazing and for
those of us
who grew up watching that batman theater
it's like this is huge huge man one of
that flash movie that's what i'm excited
about
um i like this character more
based on zack snyder's justice league
uh ezra miller's take on the character
like in in justice league it was very
like oof
this guy's talking again i thought they
were ripping civil war like hard like i
felt like they were like oh what they
just did with peter and iron man do that
even though barry like even though the
kid the ezra looked a lot older and it
just wasn't there but in in
zack snyder's justice league like he
plays way better so much so like i look
forward to watching that flash movie but
that flash movie has got me [ __ ]
turgid because like
you got ben in it and you got michael
keaton in it and
that's what we know
michael shannon i've heard uh zod comes
back who's his like one of his
henchwomen from uh man of steel
yes is confirmed i believe back as well
like they're gonna do some some
multiversal time timeline [ __ ] and then
mind you that was all before
no way home came out yeah so now in a
world where we know they were like and
marvel's like hey we're pulling back
doctor strange doing reshoots based on
the tv show we just did
there's a world where they're like you
know all right let's [ __ ] pull that
flash movie back
and [ __ ] do throw this in or up this
in or up this ante or something like
that and then we all win in that world
except for the
unless it's a filmmaker's idea if it's
not the filmmaker's idea then that
[ __ ] don't win and he's like oh
my god i was done
we're locked but i'll take as much
[ __ ] multiverse [ __ ] in there as
possible but
point being i look forward to michael
keaton being batman again and it doesn't
mean that like i don't [ __ ] dislike
the that i dislike the snyder verse or
something like that
i'm championing [ __ ] coexistence in
the world of hbo max no reason why you
can't keep that going no reese come to
terms come to the table [ __ ] you did it
once
do it again
make the cheap persian even i don't care
i just want to watch them talk to each
other um
you uh luke closing thoughts on this
movie that you absolutely love uh
closing thoughts i mean like it's a it's
a good it's a really good movie uh
to to sit down and watch with like i
mentioned sort of like
healing in mind i i'm i'm so taken by
like scenes like martha's martha kensing
with lois and then it's martian
manhunter yeah i'm on the floor because
you revealed to me it's martian
manhunter but i was like already in a
puddle of my own tears on that this is
like
a woman a woman who's lost her husband
telling a woman who's lost
her husband well husband-to-be
and it's and it's you know martha's son
and like kind of just like
sort of breaking down the grieving
process and like you know
the little beats of like lois like
getting her coffee and going every day
and going every day and like the
patterns people do when they're dealing
with loss and stuff like that
i'm like this is a comic book movie
we're doing this like it's just little
little nuances like that and it's like
if you want your action you got that too
um
everything about it just really really
like fires on a lot of different
cylinders for me um just like
even if you like people smashing into
each other in comic book movies this
one's one to throw on
literally smashing into each other like
that fight
um when he attacks the amazons oh my god
it's so good and he [ __ ] like
like side butts the horse and then
[ __ ] picks them all up by the [ __ ]
rope and swings him over his shoulder
like brutal his steppenwolf is far more
brutal than the
um
we were presented in justice league and
if just visually speaking all the time
yeah one of the coolest [ __ ] shots in
the whole movie is when he's full of
arrows and then he flexes and pops them
all [ __ ] off
that's so badass well you're talking
about doing a nightmare show and it's
like you could you could do dc's like
story time and do like all those
exposition scenes like diana like
telling me the history and me watching
these gods and like from the seas and
from the skies and the amazons fight
like fighting [ __ ] dark side and [ __ ]
like that oh my god like that that alone
is like
its own its own story its own movie
something i'd pay good money to see so
like
anywhere you chop it up and it's nice
that it's chapter wise for that like you
can find something to to enjoy and stuff
i do want to like leave with like maybe
like some homework for anybody that's
listening and like
maybe doesn't really see our perspective
or hasn't given these movies a fair spin
in a while
i would i would i would ask people to go
back and watch man of steel and watch it
in mind of like
man of steel up against
a phase one of marvel and tell me if it
doesn't check
most of the boxes you get out of phase
one maybe not iron man one
and but like
i i i honestly think that that movie
caught a lot of flack when in fact it
really could have it really on on the
page and on screen i think um
was right what exactly what it needed to
be and also it's like it's it's um
i i appreciate what you're doing but at
the same time it's like we don't even
need to compare it to marvel it's its
own thing like it's its own distinct
flavor auteur driven and that's what's
kind of beautiful about it when you're
like
you know the marvel universe
is very auteur driven for sure and that
auteur is generally
kevin feige without a doubt um one of my
favorite if not my favorite filmmaker
working today he's telling the longest
[ __ ] movie story i've ever seen and
it's i'm still in
and he you know is works with a bunch of
great filmmakers to do that and
you know um zach has a just
his own
you know he's kind of he's like kevin
foggy if kevin foggy actually directed
the movies without a doubt because he's
the guy that created their universe and
shaped it and was like this is where
this is and this is this and this is the
lord this is the mythology this is how
we're carrying it forward
from movie to movie this movie is
spinning off like he's the closest thing
that they've had
to a kevin feige and he was a directing
kevin feige
why let that asset go
i mean i hear you man dollar bills it's
hard like when it's hard to make these
movies work uh like in a movie theater
when your best versions end up not your
best versions but
the ideal version of a lot of these
flicks have been the longer version we
watch on blu-ray and now we watch on
streaming and stuff so i feel like now
we've unlocked the code like we're
sitting here in 2022 where it's like 10
years ago aquaman for some reason is a
laughingstock character nobody's talking
about superman and my friend group you
know what i mean and
uh
like you know zack snyder is is quote
unquote divisive now he's like king of
the he's king you know toast of the town
king of the world aquaman is the coolest
person alive
and superman is is like is back in a big
bad way we had superman rise from the
dead and and on uh on
justice league and stuff but we also
like superman and lois season two starts
tonight that show's good like you talk
about other iterations
show a cw show that's on hbo maps yeah
man it's good and it's like uh it's like
i can watch black suit superman like
frost breath and eye laser and do crazy
[ __ ] against god and i can also watch a
nice family drama with tyler heckland
who's also battling aliens and doing
some cool battle and stuff but you know
you you can do both and i really
appreciate when you get to have the
multiverse and stuff like that it's
crazy short but watching superman beat
the [ __ ] out of steppenwolf is one of
the
most deeply satisfying superhero movie
moments
i've ever enjoyed like oh my god look at
him and he depicts superman
like it's tough to see his superman in
action because he makes a move as
quickly as he would move sure um you
know it's
absolutely breathtaking but you know
watching
uh
the trinity come together in bvs is one
thing we're watching like [ __ ]
justice league
flat out murder this [ __ ] before
sending them back to darkseid and by the
way
you know we could do a half an hour
alone on [ __ ] the first cinematic
appearance of dark side but he jumps out
of the carrier yeah ravaging fantastic
[ __ ] shot and like then just the view
into apocalypse i'm like there's assad
and there's granny goodness and there's
like an army of [ __ ] you know um
parademons waiting to [ __ ] go
um you know it's all there table's
[ __ ] sad
just like you've got me like chills
right now it's like oh my god the pair
of demons they're buried until the
mother box awakens them but superman's
buried and they can win if superman
doesn't come back from the dead it's
like
guess what guys you made an excellent
movie and i'm here to tell the world if
you haven't seen it
zach center's justice league on hbo max
at home so if you haven't given the
forum most people i'm sure listening to
this have made the deep dive but
we are talking about a pop cultural
event from last year
not this year 2022. [ __ ] weird that's
2022 that's strange
that being said
if you haven't watched yet that's not
covered that's weed if you haven't
watched yet we hope fingers crossed um
if you haven't watched it yet
take the time if four hours seems
intimidating break it up he broke it up
for you it's done chapter style if you
watch it on hbo max and i think that's
the only place you can watch it i don't
think he's legit they've made it
transactional yet
uh i haven't made a blu-ray yet no you
buy the blu-ray but it doesn't give you
a digital code they're like you can only
watch this digitally on hbo oh
it's a move it's a very interesting
movie there's power moves i got people
to join up in the first place
they break it up the chapters for you
where you can like [ __ ] do it in
nibbles if if that's how you want to do
it they're less than an hour about the
chapter each chapter they're like 40 45
minutes so it is very digestible not a
way to make it work but to be fair like
uh watching it from end to end is an
experience as well i watched it
by myself the first time when they
dropped it that night and then like
right after our special
and then i watched it with jennifer and
that was a real litmus test where you
know
she'd been watching marvel stuff and
she's like what else you got and i was
like well
do you want to be in like the [ __ ]
hip kids
do you want to dive into justice league
and she absolutely [ __ ] loved it
she's like that is so
beautiful yeah she loved all the wonder
woman stuff and
loved the whole movie she was into it
man and like you know she ain't deep in
that mythology um
so it
it it's it was a cult pop cultural event
of last year but no less important
this year i know some people like hot
take talking about zack snyder's justice
league but
uh i knew the kids wanted to talk about
it well it's film school right like when
i was in film school it was like word
two years removed from like
we're in the middle of house and house
of cards and learning about it we're
learning we're watching the sopranos and
studying it so you know i mean like i
don't think if this if that's did they
show you guys sopranos in film school i
swear we had to watch like i had a tv
class where i had to watch sopranos
pilot breaking bad like all these other
like current shows that were had just
wrapped up and stuff and that's all to
say that like if this is quote unquote a
film school podcast then it's you know
this is a big enough significant enough
film event for whenever somebody's ready
they can toss it on and learn the lesson
where we're laying down and we also
talked about last issue we're like we're
going to [ __ ] don't look up next
episode so we'll get into
uh don't look up but uh we'll jump all
over basically the idea is whoever's
sitting in the chair man we're going to
talk about what their
passion is i saw dr josh roush today i
was like hey man we're doing this thing
you want to do an episode and he picked
a movie where i was like you know what
it ain't new
what flick but yeah
yeah i can't tease it but it's one
that's very passionate he's passionate
about
and uh peter jackson's king kong i know
very well wow what a [ __ ] i wish it
were crap
that's another one
i'll give you this much just black and
white okay
um so he was you know everybody's got
one and usually that movie leads you on
to a discussion
onto like a director's entire [ __ ]
canon and stuff and i'm sure this ain't
the last time we'll talk about
zack snyder um but uh
but boy oh boy we went long long and
hard on him man
uh there's a lot of love in the room
for him and uh and for zack snyder's
justice league and that was luke's idea
so give it up for luke if you're like oh
my god i can't believe they [ __ ]
talked about a movie that came out last
year i had to we're not but again like
just because we started with licorice
pizza which is out now current doesn't
mean like you know that and that's what
it's going to be the only thing it's
going to be is
people are going to sit on a [ __ ]
podcast you're going to hear some
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and talk about movies
which
i'm sure is revolutionary on the
internet i don't think anyone's thought
to talk about movies on the internet
prior to this also things are very
interesting right now in terms of yeah
like licorice pizza had an interesting
release in theaters
i don't think there's a more interesting
release
than justice league on hbo max because
it it was their flagship like by our app
and they're made and i did buy their app
because of it and they have amazing
things on the app and i'm not just
blowing smoke like
i like tcm i like comedy central i like
i've been watching south park non-stop
you know like it's a great app and then
they also have like their original
contents really coming through so
we are talking about what is currently
happening even though the movies from
last year the hbo max app and what's
happening with streaming is like so
[ __ ] important this is film school
man like they didn't make no excuses
about making you watch [ __ ] sopranos
we ain't making no excuses here
we'll talk about what we talk about and
you know people be able to see from week
to week like yeah i [ __ ] go with them
on that and sometimes i'm sure they'll
be like i don't give a [ __ ] about those
people
but uh that's the beauty of film man you
ain't gotta like it all and stuff you
should try it all
and uh you know if you try it you're
like hey for me you get to move on and
[ __ ] but
in this very short life kids it's very
important to extol the virtues of that
which you love and you know
it's a waste of time to [ __ ]
spend time kicking the [ __ ] you don't
like move on i saw somebody defended
this week online like art has always
involved criticism and it's like
there's criticism and then there's
campaigning against [ __ ] things
because you hate them and [ __ ] it's like
who's got that kind of
[ __ ] time there's a currency in it
you can make money on it on the internet
you can get some clicks by hating on
[ __ ] but you ain't gonna hear any hate
here kids you're gonna hear a lot of
love if you're waiting to tune in to
film school fridays be like and this is
when they tear this [ __ ] thing apart
you know move on kid there ain't no
wrestling match going on here nobody
gonna get hit by a [ __ ]
chair for heaven's sakes
um
it is uh a celebration
of the cinematic arts kids and this week
we spent time
uh fellating zack snyder and zack
snyder's justice league next week
i'm going to call it just in case it
don't wind up in yeah don't mess up adam
okay
don't look up what's good you know i
worked for him he worked for mackay yeah
i when i interned out here uh he seems
like a nice guy he was like honestly i
met him one time i drove his tesla shook
he shook my hand with his oscar
award-winning writer's fingers
feel the magic
i carried it for a few years
he's got like eight feet on you too
right yeah he's a giant right he's so
tall i couldn't believe it but now it's
like you know back then it was like oh
it's adam mckay he's made my favorite
comedies and now he's like adam [ __ ]
mckay
oscar award winner you know what i mean
it's so cool everyone shut up he made an
important movie oh my god more than one
yeah
um
the uh the good news is on this show
uh you got a cool ass perspective you
maybe didn't normally get man
boots on the ground
exhibitor
they exhibited the right attitude
something exhibited you gotta ask
yourself that question man
before you do anything in life is it
being exhibited
it's good that's a rule to live by
before you make a move in life before
you do something say something [ __ ]
just always wonder
is this being exhibited
and then
you know like you won't get caught like
[ __ ]
well christian battle when he yelled at
the guy remember that oh we can't we
won't forget about that we we talk about
it we quote it often we all heard it oh
good for you
you prick an incredible [ __ ]
impression of it
and by all reports he seems like a nice
guy too but he just [ __ ] that's a
whole episode like i lost it that's a
whole other episode to talk about
because just don't trash it i'll trash
your lights if you trash my scene i'll
get it trash
your lights then don't trash my scene we
were so nice all episode we were so nice
i think when he came out and he
apologized he went on k rock and he was
like look i was an [ __ ] blah blah
blah but at the end of the day it comes
down to this
this is a business full of adult
children people who are paid to make
pretend for a living and
creative people
you know
like all babies are used to getting
their way and when you [ __ ] tell a
baby no [ __ ] [ __ ] go south and so
sometimes if you're not playing right
yeah as when we were kids somebody's
like that blaine right they just lose it
on youtube
you know [ __ ] the passions flare i
personally have not ever gotten to a
place where
like i've lost it on a set like to that
degree
that's good
yeah i i you know i've i've been heated
on a set or been like oh man not heated
but more like frustrated that
something didn't go my way but in a real
like privileged way
like you know oh i didn't get the pony i
wanted mommy like kind of thing
so but you know that is i think his
excuse as well was like i'm doing a
scene where my emotions are running high
which movie was it terminator salvation
that's where it falls apart you tell me
you tell me he's doing a david o'russell
movie or a [ __ ] dark knight i'm like
oh yeah yeah yeah i get it but you're
still working really hard for mcg yeah
up to 11. that's the other thing to
carry that poor cross and it's like what
movie did you do it on he was like a mcj
movie might but bowel reports like
doesn't sound like that guy normally
just sounds like a
you know [ __ ] dude but more
importantly
it was exhibited it was exhibited so
internationally as jake asked always ask
yourself in life
in the british fashion
is it exhibited
that'll keep you in line it works
your words your actions everything your
dick
don't pull your dick out without asking
is it exhibited important to think about
very important
if you learn nothing else from this
podcast film school fridays the lesson
is
is it exhibited
uh there it is kids
for film school fridays i'm kevin smith
i'm jks weissman lucas guy taylor and
you have been schooled
[Music]
this has been a smodco internet
production
sip
only at smodcast.com
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
ten year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old i'm kevin smith